what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
start do not forget subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
the way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos as you guys already know
if you have watched two or more of my
videos and you do not subscribe we have
beef okay beef people a couple
announcements before we start the show
the first is that we have two clips
channels um the first is Pearl daily and
the second is just pearly Clips on top
of that guys we have four memberships
membership tiers the first gets you to
be a part of our live chat it's only
five dollars a month that is the price
of a cup of coffee it helps support the
show and get new equipment updates for
the studio the second is you get the ten
dollar tier which is a you get to be a
part of our Discord and our behind the
scenes Vlogs the third you get to
connect with me on social media and the
fourth you get a one-on-one call with me
once a month some people do this they
have questions about the show other
people
um want YouTube advice so if you guys
want to sign up for that I really
recommend the one-on-one call with me
once a month also guys um they deleted
my Instagram
I know oh I know they took it away it's
like they'll let all these only fans
models stay on IG but I call a girl a
whale one time after she anyways anyways
my point is follow my new Instagram it's
just pearly things one
um so as you just put in just pearly
things and then one also guys um they
took away my first second third and
fourth Tick Tock accounts so go follow
my fifth and sixth Tick Tock account
it's just pearly things top five and
just pearly things six
um on top of that guys we have a new
channel um we're calling it wife School
we've already um we've already recorded
episode one so go subscribe to that the
link should be in the description and if
it's not I'm sure if my manager will put
it in the chat
um we want to get to a thousand
followers or a thousand subscribers
before we drop the first video so make
sure you go subscribe
um and lastly the top Super chatter for
today um you get my autograph and I will
send it to you so that's for the top
Super chatter today so um today we have
a lovely panel so why don't we go around
everyone say your name your age your
relationship status and a fun fact about
yourself so starting here and then you
can go around
sure I'm your host Rob
um I'm married I'm 35. uh fun fact about
me
um I interviewed uh I'll be honest Mario
um and I interviewed Craig David and
when I interview Craig David I told him
he might be my dad
I see that yeah
um now he ranks uh my Facebook statuses
is complicated and
um I'm 27.
um yes me I'm sorry I kind of did a bit
of intro my last one um I am in a
relationship and my fun fact is uh
Nathaniel used to be my personal trainer
yeah so my fun fact is he used to train
me back in the day when I used to live
in London wow yeah
um Emilia I'm 24
um
single
fun fact I took shrooms this morning
[Laughter]
wow wow okay
go ahead I just was not expecting that
okay my name is Iman I'm 21. I'm single
and fun fact about me is I have a
brother who was one years old so 20
years Gap oh wow
okay so um who knows who Tom Brady is
yeah yeah
and you don't
no you know who Tom Brady is
oh wow all right Tom Brady is one of the
argue I'm gonna chat don't don't kill me
I'm not a huge football person but uh
arguably the greatest quarterback of all
time
um or one of depends who you who you ask
they'll argue about that I don't really
care
um so um Tom Brady married Giselle and I
Gisele Boonton
I don't know basically
supermodel okay fun fact about her she
dated Leonardo DiCaprio for like five
years before before Tom Brady
um so um Tom Brady is one of my fans
sent this the greatest NFL quarterback
of all time with seven championships
rings and five MVP awards in his 22 year
career Tom Brady is 45 years old and
worth 250 million dollars Giselle is 42
year old two years old and is worth 400
million dollars they have two kids and
they are seeking um they just got
divorced or they're filing for divorce
and they're seeking joint custody Tom
Brady has one child from a previous
relationship
Giselle states that the plan was that
after the 2021 season Tom was supposed
to stay home with the kids so she could
go back to work as a supermodel at 42.
it's a little delusional
things to consider Giselle was Alpha
Widow do you guys know what an alpha
Widow is no what does that mean so it
basically just means okay you ever seen
a girl that can't get over that X like
that girl like she always goes back that
acts every time she breaks up with one
guy back to that X back to that it's
just like basically a girl sees him as
the best she could have done and that
guy had like the biggest imprint or
impact on her life basically
um allegedly Alpha widowed by Leo
Leonardo DiCaprio she was with Leo
before Tom she had no idea who Tom was
when they met and didn't know about his
status as a quarterback for the Patriots
when he was courting her What was Tom's
home life like that he didn't want to
retire rumors were that Giselle was
impossible to deal with she said I don't
want to have to be his caretaker when he
gets old because of his injuries Tom
Brady has doubled down on his commitment
to the Tampa Bay Buccaneers and says
that he isn't retiring anytime soon
so question for the men
if you became a one percent man or maybe
10 and you had to choose between your
purpose
and your wife what would you choose
purpose purpose purpose right away why
well she's not gonna stay around when
I'm finished with my purpose from the
sounds of it
um you can always get another wife like
respectfully respectfully
you know but is this that the purpose is
going to last longer you're going to be
more fulfilled
um I think everything you get from your
purpose she'll be getting all the
benefits of that to some degree you'll
be a happier happier husband you'll be a
better father and it'll impact their
family positively
yeah you got you got things to do as a
man and I think um well I strongly
believe that if you put a woman
or a relationship above your purpose
then you're destined for failure because
it's you got to be able to keep that
relationship going and
um yeah you'll be sorry how would you
feel about your wife having you make
that choice are ultimatum's ever good in
a relationship yeah it speeds up it
speeds things up
I don't wanna I don't want to like be in
a situation where you're giving me these
trying to give me these ultimatums when
um like we have kids together or I've
already
um taken you down the aisle and then
you're coming with these random or
meetings and stuff like that yeah give
them to me early so we can get this um
we know where we're at and she should
have known she knew what she signed up
for like she knew the game she knew that
this is important to him and if she's
also like impossible to deal with it's
like what we spoke about on I was on
here before she's just giving them a
headache is this more reason for him to
go in and play sport and and follow his
purpose have you guys ever been given an
ultimatum
um
no no no no no
not even like small ones like I want you
to stop not serious not serious ones not
serious ones it's just like you know
what I have been given those um
those uh random questions you know them
games that you play like what would you
do if I
those are the worst games to play ever
like oh what would you do like if I got
with Megan good and like yeah I mean
just stuff like that stuff that's never
really gonna happen but they just breed
a little bit of fear into your
relationship so uh yeah I don't play
those games but um well yeah
question for the women
you're wealthy and your husband is
wealthy you want him to spend less time
at work or retire and he doesn't do it
do you stay or do you leave
kitso without kids
um let's both give me both uh with kids
you stay without kids you compromise and
so I think um if you're both wealthy I
get a man without a purpose is less
attractive anyway you want a man who's
got a purpose and he's got those things
but
um part of the purpose should be to
build a happy marriage as well and I
think that should be embedded in his
purpose and if it involves completely
neglecting the marriage and the kids
that's also it requires some compromise
I wouldn't want it to just be you go do
your thing and then we don't matter
because the kids need you I need you we
need you and we need that Foundation at
home as well so I would say without kids
compromise with kids stay
for kids is it more to do with time then
time yeah you just need that time a bit
more
okay what about you um I don't think I
would ask him to retire anyway because
as she said Like a Man Without purpose
it doesn't like you need to Value the
purpose of the man as in like he needs
to value that as well right so I don't
think I would ask such questions because
I know how important that is for him and
I chose him when he had the purposeful
so what's the point of me asking that
later but if he's neglecting the
marriage then we need both of us to be
in common ground if that makes sense so
maybe we can find a solution to it but
so I would say I would say I would say
what about you hmm
um yeah I agree with you I think I
probably wouldn't ask anyway just
because exactly wouldn't want him to
just be there with like I don't know
sounds boring but then if that is what I
wanted and he didn't do it I would
probably leave just because it's what I
wanted and it didn't happen and I get
bored easily so I don't know you think
we should leave every time we don't get
what we want I think me personally if it
was something very serious where it's
like I feel like it could either go this
way or I can't do it anymore then I'd
rather not do it anymore but I don't see
myself getting to a point
I don't know
okay have you ever been with a guy
that's really busy and really on his
purpose because it you almost feel like
you're single when you are with someone
that busy woman you do feel like well I
watched I watched my dad do that growing
yeah and as a woman you just you live
like a single it's okay if you're okay
with it but it does feel like you're a
single woman and if you've got kids it
does feel like being a single mum it's
just that you get the perks of a good
life and you know get that Financial but
in terms of your day-to-day it's it's
like being a thing modern women are sold
a dream like you can have everything and
you can't if you want a guy that's
successful you think he's not gonna work
a ton that's mad yeah that's Madness I'm
like my dad worked
I don't know 80 hours a week most of my
life you think you're going to be the
center of his world oh my God no yeah it
makes sense yeah it makes complete sense
all right question for the girls
if a guy had everything you wanted would
you overlook cheating
no because that wouldn't be part of what
I wanted yeah
everything okay
Interruption
the catalog yes the cup alarm right
there
[Music]
um what do you mean
um because like if you had everything I
wanted then he would be loyal I guess
and he wouldn't oh yeah but outside of
that so so okay okay let's let me let me
do you how tall do you want a guy to be
um I like same height or taller okay so
how tall are you five nine five eight
let's give him what what you seem like a
six three kind of girl
but I can sit off the same height
yeah okay so let's say six three he's
got money status could you overlook
cheating you don't think you could uh
and you don't have to work again
yeah I don't know you know I think I
probably could just because I I don't
know okay and you said no it's like
everything I wanted and Advance like my
career and all of that then sure okay
what about you no it's not something I
would accept to be honest would you
prefer a guy you liked less and that was
faithful yeah 100 okay you too yeah I
think you know what I wish I was and
this is not because there's anything
wrong in forgiving and moving on I wish
I was more forgiving but I think
um I'm not strong enough and I'm not
forgiving enough as a person and it
makes me too insecure if I was more
secure in myself and I was more able to
let go it'd be fine but because I'm
already not the most secure person there
is adding that to it I just won't be a
good partner going forward I won't be
the best version of me I'll you'll get a
different version of me and one that is
not worth staying with so I wouldn't be
able to for his for the sake of us I I
don't think it would work I think yeah
um I hate what you guys are saying but
yeah
um I believe that I think it kind of
just depends on how how you discover
that he's cheating if you know that when
he says he's going I don't know to
Manchester or to Liverpool or something
like that then that's what he's doing
um but you don't have like actual
evidence I don't feel like he would go
looking for the evidence if he's got
your whole situation set up yeah if you
get embarrassed and someone's coming up
to you like yo then I feel like maybe
it's different it's a bit different but
I feel I think a lot of women would play
a blind eye to it as long as they don't
feel publicly disrespected I think the
thing is they
you know what um the thing is
women share men all the time if you're
dating someone casually for example or
if you're in a situationship you're
usually sharing them and you kind of
already know I think it's just like what
you said about it don't just want it
rubbed in their faces but you'd be
surprised really surprised on what some
women will put up with if they're with
someone they actually like
um
do you sometimes they prefer
you know the situation rather than
because they do know you've got a mean
person on the side yeah yeah I do things
they are more comfortable I think women
would be more comfortable with that
because there's no suspicion involved
it's actually like that's what you're
doing he's cheating on you and he wants
you to be faithful though that's the
thing it's not like a free fall
it's just like okay I'm doing my thing
but hey you got you got a pattern as
well it depends at the stage as well and
answer your question so
um you can tell them from the get-go
this is the situation yeah and then they
have the choice if they want to get on
board yeah or sometimes it doesn't come
out until later and then they have to
find out and I've I can't speak for
anyone else but I've had I've had
someone say to me I don't care I just
don't want to see it
in general like modern women like are
side chicks for sure yeah 100 I mean if
you look at dating app data it's you
can't deny it we swipe right five
percent of the time on the same guys
basically and then on top of that like
what what comes first typically
typically and I know I know there's
exceptions but sex are relationships so
yeah so he's right you start off as a
side chick do you think Modern Men are
side men without realizing because men
go for the top women as well either I
don't think no no no that's not
statistically true they swipe right 45
of the time and it's higher on who do
they like who do they actually want to
be with men really aren't that picky to
be fair like honestly like I mean you
you guys can correct me if I'm wrong if
you're hot enough nice enough young
enough they're they're cool what if
you're not hot if you're out
I mean
the majority of women are not hot I know
it looks like I disagree
no I think it looks like it because the
majority of women I think the majority
of women we see publicly on TV on
Instagram these are the women the
beautiful women put themselves out there
but the majority of women when you're
walking into Tesco are not stunners you
don't walk into Tesco's and be like oh
my God
it's usually
really but it's usually based on their
own poor choices though if even in the
U.S here and everyone will call America
fat but I looked at the data here it's
not much better yeah but you're in the
top 20 of women if you're in shape yeah
so all you have to do is be in shape
most guys are fine but I do think it's
not um just women that go for high
quality the way men flock to beautiful
women and high quality women is no
different to how women flock to high
quality men if you take a girl who's not
attractive and is not in shape she
doesn't have that same success online
dating she doesn't have that same
success with men she doesn't have many
ideas
I'm telling you you're wrong like that's
statistically no no no no no no no it's
statistically wrong an average chick has
more options than a top man if you look
at dating if you an average girl so
average chick gets more matches than the
top men but matches is sex we're talking
about investment women don't care about
sex you've got to remember that you're
measuring men and women on the same
standard who gets stamina level of sex
yeah okay of course sexifying but women
value investment men value sex so if you
look at the investment an unattractive
woman gets like how many dates does she
get taken on does she get taken
seriously do they introduce her to her
friends and family that is comparable to
you know that's a foreign
success in dating by sex
because if that's what we're measuring
and fine
delusional to think that like the top
men have all the leverage they do it's
not comparable the top women do not have
as much leverage as the top man I think
and if they do and if they do give it
five years I'm sorry like like you hit
30 it's not the same yeah but I do think
top women get the same reaction as top
men and they have the same and I think
more because you know what it is a Top
Value man well most Top Value men that I
know of have very silent Instagrams they
are busy they are CEOs you don't see
them posting up and this whereas
beautiful women they're in your face all
day every day so their DMS are insane
insane so on a day-to-day basis without
any effort that woman can have five six
seven men paying her not just going on
dates with their cash up this that and
the other I don't think a Top Value man
has it as easy as a Top Value woman and
men flock the top I just think I think
the difference is the Top Value man is
satisfied with like like
um like the top like they say that eight
nines and tens are for the streets
forever like I've just heard this phrase
in red pill because like if a girl's an
eight she needs a nine or a ten if a
guy's an eight he's okay with a six I
Know I Know Rich guys
most men will cheat most men have give
if given beautiful models every day
they're gonna say yes one day so an
eight will be happy with the six where
the eight that's a girl needs a nine or
a ten so it's a smaller pool that she's
going to be satisfied with I think guys
are just a bit more realistic like long
term with like they just content with
how things are do you pursue a pretty
girl the same way you'd pursue an
average girl would you invest the same
do they get the same Nathaniel out of
you a pretty girl and an average girl
yeah
um
I'll probably are we talking about I'm
sexually attracted to both
no your one is average you can take it
let's make one a six one and eight one's
a six you can't use seven yeah
all right um one's a six one's at eight
the six I don't really see me checking
for the six I'll be honest thank you
um the eight but there's I'll say this
here because there's makeup yeah I feel
like money is the man's makeup because
there's makeup a lot of women can look
like I could think about three different
kind of women that all women can look
like if they if they had the right
makeup
at the end of the day if we're talking
about like you know uh in the morning I
have Peak she's six that's
yeah listen I've seen I've seen some
serious Transformations so at your best
you're six then
it's mad yeah because I feel like
there's a lot of talk about high value
men but do you know what it's like 18 19
year old like pretty girls getting flown
out in private jets and so look how men
treat high value or beautiful women they
drop all the rules for beautiful women
and the same applies for high value men
but they drop every rule for a beautiful
girl are you arguing that beautiful
women have the same leverage that high
value men have is that is if not more
because what percent of women are
beautiful like I'm saying no there's
there's a new girl turning 22 every day
high value men are rare and women women
they age out at like 20. it was rare but
now we've got an Instagram which means a
a rich guy in Nigeria can send you
Millions a rich guy in Qatar can send
you media we have polarized it so that
high value men uh who aren't bait or
aren't big on social media are limited
to the women around them whereas
beautiful women are exposed to the world
but yeah right right so they might get
sex from him but she's not the main
chick
when we established that you can be side
chick even if you're average you can be
a side chick
you're right you're sharing even that's
your name
but that man still has the leverage
because he gets to pick who is who gets
commitment that's why he has the
leverage high leverages in the fact that
she doesn't want commitment from him she
lifestyle from you right now so her
Leverage is I think we're talking about
two different things so I'm talking
about women that want a ring and Men
men and men that want sex okay okay so
okay if we're measuring it by investment
and six then can pretty girls get money
yeah yeah like can they get lifestyle
yeah
how long can how long can they keep that
up they have these rules that they don't
want to get cheated on and you know they
want to be they want to keep this up and
and there's no one else anyone that's
high value men how long do you reckon uh
women have that that um leverage for if
she's pregnant forever if she's not
pregnant forever not forever there's no
such thing it's pregnant
baby as long as the baby's alive for as
long as the babies no what wait a
faithful a faithful high value man
you're saying a baby mama
it's that leverage because you get that
leverage it's not that okay so that's a
good life but she gets that leverage for
as long as she has that child is that
all women want is not to work I think so
I think that's what people want to do
no they want to work but they want a man
that can make a life that if she didn't
work it'd be all right yeah basically I
think yeah
they want the best of everything yes if
you tell them that I don't want you to
work you're you're controlling them or
you're oppressing them or you're the
patriarchy but if you say look if you
can if you want to work it's cool if you
want to work that's cool as well we're
good for money and it's a different
conversation yeah we don't want to have
to work so speaking of money
okay so so you could argue right women
want the rich guy
until can you pull up the picture
um
trouble in Paradise oh wait wait hold on
sorry for the guy from EastEnders oh can
you can you put on the screen blessing
okay so back to back to Tom Brady
Giselle buditan I I think I said that
wrong
I'm gonna just call her B and Jiu Jitsu
instructor domain Valente have raised a
lot of Suspicion as the possible to
possible romantic ties but we at least
know one of the reasons he's traveled to
her with Costa Rica he's training her
and Tom Brady's kids so basically she
was cheating on the rich guy Juju Jitsu
that's what's gonna happen though man
that's what's gonna happen I think um
when when you're around
um like when you go if a woman has a
high value men she she's gonna cheat
with someone close because it's not you
have to be in the circle to kind of be
around anyways you're gonna have to look
around at who's available and it's going
to be someone close it kind of feels a
bit vindictive you know because when men
if if men go and cheat you know the the
the men that go and cheat they'll maybe
go outside of the circle far far away
where we're with the women it's very
it's not because at all right I have a
question would you rather him [ __ ] a
stranger your best friend no I'm just
saying with the with it being worse more
vindictive for women to find someone
around because it's like okay it's maybe
been bubbling and the tension was there
and then it happened but with a guy
you're saying he left town went town
over town and tried to look for somebody
that you won't find out like that's
worse
consideration yeah
forgivable than like a happy accident
because you're not that's not a happy
accident that's literally someone in
this case said training her kids so this
guy is all right yeah
and him and he's got she's got the balls
basically to get involved with this guy
who's around his kids around kids maybe
like him and trust him
okay yeah but it doesn't matter I'm just
thinking okay like put yourself if all
right you have a boyfriend you're really
into or husband let's say husband he
cheats it's just a one-time thing no
feelings involved this girl just threw
it on him and he he went with this he's
he's a dude okay thought she was hot
that's it never talk to her again or he
screwed a girl he has feelings for
um probably the one that he doesn't have
feelings for because it's like why are
you throwing it away like if you had
feelings for someone it's like okay fine
act on your feelings
some random person that's that feels a
bit worse to me really that's
interesting for me like I would if it's
just a random girl like whatever we can
like I can get over it oh I don't know
because that's right if you have food I
don't know if you have feelings for them
it's like okay there's reason behind it
but you're gonna do that for no reason
that just seems this one has betrayal
and public disrespect yeah yeah you know
what I notice women that have high value
men once they've had kids with high
value men they will sleep they have the
same mating strategy as men they will
sleep with young guys that make them
feel attractive he doesn't have to have
money Kim did it Madonna's doing it
she's doing it once they have their kids
and they've got the father of their
child and he's high value then she goes
back to just whoever I want yeah
they become just like men yeah so that's
like what do you think women value more
in money or looks feelings they matter
how a man makes them feel and when he
spends a lot of money on you you feel
expensive
okay one or two I didn't say feelings
to the question I asked money or looks
I'm always going to say the way they
feel if you're in trouble okay okay the
next money your looks
so why they cheat basically right no no
I'm saying what do you think women
prefer
I guess money these days money you think
what do you think money I think it looks
I I think looks too actually it looks
for sure you know you you know how you
know that's Cap City now you know that's
cap do you know that boy that um J house
says wait wait we're talking about I'm
ugly man making pretty money that they
they don't look like people still
probably getting girls because he was a
Trapper because you trap and the
lifestyle that he portray is like oh man
even if you may not have money to come
with it that portrays
money regardless
of the money
okay this is this is my theory I'm this
is I don't I don't know if this is facts
or whatever but I feel like if a girl is
dating a guy and she's not like
genuinely attracted to him she'll cheat
yeah
she's still gonna cheat if that guy
comes along and he's that big yeah
for man with that has investment because
like if a girl values and looks more
chances are that something that she
feels more attractive when she's with an
attractive man if she values money more
she already knows she's attractive she
wants lifestyle more so that's why
pretty girls go for rich men
yeah
I mean Women Marry a lifestyle I do
agree with you yeah but I just I just
think the more like like genuine
connection comes more from looks but but
if it's but if it's money like I've just
noticed that girls seem to be using him
more or she's not really attracted to
him and like doesn't rain because it
looks also using someone look at that
Uncle in your DM that is sending you a
Madness and he's a prince of somewhere
and he's saying he'll he'll buy this and
do all this kind of stuff here and look
how you're treating him compared to this
person that you feel like like let's say
eight let's say eight exactly let's say
you girls like AJ
same way that girls will actually over
AJ right if he didn't have the money
right yeah they'll pick that over this
Uncle sending you a random DM promising
you however many however much money and
stuff like that so I think if the woman
has her own money as well mine doesn't
even matter yeah or just even your own
values I'm not gonna lie the money won't
matter money always matters in some
degree not as much and no I think no I
don't I don't believe this guy's jobs to
look good that's the women's job to look
that's why it's so hot when they do like
I kind of disagree with that one still
as as a self-respecting as a guy you
definitely need to keep yourself up in
maintenance oh yeah I'm saying that but
I'm saying that
looks like the levels are different in
regards to look so the importance is
that you don't have to do too much
compared to the females yeah and we can
supplement in other areas right so
that's what I say about that so you can
be funny you can be like yeah stuff like
that yeah
we can but we we don't if we aren't if
we're not attracted to us our funniness
is not going to make you more attractive
yeah funny I think for men it does no I
just think money is the man's makeup
that's it
if it's not good if it's not nice little
muscles what do you think more or even
humor and stuff like even if a guy is
ugly and he's funny but then if a guy is
like oh yeah funny
signals social status and women are very
attracted to statuses why do you think
what do you think a check mark does
wonders on Instagram the confidence
how many how many ugly guys I think I've
gotten attractive girls with that
checkmarks can you have status without
money can you have social studies
no I don't think think so because your
status is intangible it's imaginary but
with money it means that you've actually
put in some work and you've got
somewhere it doesn't mean money alone
can give you status because you could
just win the lottery or you could just
you know get one here but I don't think
status alone is enough you know what's
interesting women are more attracted to
men that have made money lost it and
then made it again yeah
there was some like poll done where it's
like do you would you rather have a guy
that like made money lost it and then
made it again or a guy that just like no
no slowly like grew money over time or
something it was something like that but
women picked number two because we're
attracted to Risk Takers Risk Takers
implies that they're able to
recalibrate yeah and protect in the
future yeah
why are you laughing
oh [ __ ] women women make so much
um like decisions based on how they feel
yeah at that time yep that is just
hilarious
designed by God I just hope it's is it
working for you guys I just hope it's
working if it's working I do I do agree
earlier what you said about the it's
about how you make someone feel I don't
think it's relevant to them exactly to
the money it looks however how you make
them it's all about how to make it feel
how they make you feel and the
experience that you bring them and what
triggers in their minds yeah I'll give
you an example so my block list is full
of people yeah men women whoever yeah
but if I was to unblock someone and
start talking to them again they're
instantly going to romanticize any
experience that we've had and that's
that's more important so if you've made
them feel even if you've made them feel
shitty yeah that will work but it's
similarly like why women that didn't
grow up with money if they meet a really
rich guy he's most attractive man in the
room because she feels now financially
secure she hasn't felt for in a long
time most women
less attractive are more likely to be
invested in a man who's attracted looks
is more important so it's about how you
make someone feel rather than just
generally interesting women are more
picky physically than men nowadays
there's different studies that say like
women are pickier when it comes to look
similar yeah is that weird not really
but it is when you're you're not
actually going towards the guys so you
know you're just showing in your gene
pool
but that's why I'm you know body
positivity is not for men it's just for
women yeah in fact fat guys are still
fat guys short guys are still short guys
no one cares about that okay body
positivity if there is a short man
shaming I'm sure
like five was it five seven energy or
whatever
I actually think is it is being a short
man the equivalent of being an
overweight woman what classifies as a
short man as well um
short men are allowed to be angry and
overweight women kind of aren't allowed
to be angry so they are though what are
you talking about
if a fat woman's angry it's like oh it's
weird it's worse than a short man being
angry you see a short angry man every
day
you could at least like do something to
be able to change it but when you're
short as a guy yeah anyway that's true
people syndrome as well because they
just go mad for no reason yeah I think I
think that yeah
I've been attacked by a fact yeah
first-hand experience I've never been
attacked by a short man but the fat
chicks come for you why they have to be
jolly man look here it's like a trigger
basically yeah with all this body
positivity is going on but you know
what's worse about this and what's the
frustration that comes from it like
that's something that can be done but
women will like ridicule guys for their
height and they there's nothing they can
do now you can get you can get you can
get um
okay but I'll give you two sentences
right what do you think would have more
of a public uproar so I say I don't date
short guys
men don't like fat chicks second one
yeah of course
the media I feel like the media is
controlled by it no no feminine energy
by both groups yeah like I say I don't
date short guys and I never really have
a reaction so I don't get shots but if I
say men don't ditch fat chicks typically
I have this in one time I said I have
never dated a girl over size 12. it got
picked up by UK gossip and everyone
slated me for it do you guys ever date
fat chicks
size 12 no I know some girls in science
told them God damn they're volunteers
good juicy I wouldn't call that fat yeah
you got fat on you but that's not fat in
it yeah so like it kind of depends you
could be fat and shape naturally fat
what no shape no shape you're not
attractive like that's that's something
that needs to be worked on yeah I think
that it's okay to accept that being over
even when I put on weight I accept that
I'm not attractive This Moment Like if I
put on weight but I don't think how much
weight you're pulling away you don't
think you try to do um I've never been
that big the most I've ever been is
probably 65 kg I think that's nice
but for me that's that and then I do
just accept I'm less attractive I don't
think I don't get offended but how how
do you like are there any indicators
like within like the guys that approach
you depending on what your weight is yes
you know it is we're going to talk about
it but yeah I know I've lost weight when
I appeal to a certain demographic and I
know I've gained weight when I appeal to
a different demographic and make of that
what you will yeah
okay okay okay so following Tom and Tom
and Giselle
how long is too long to move on or do
you think that after a divorce there's a
certain amount of time you should wait
to move on yeah yeah
[Music]
okay so how how long is that I'd say
maybe a year I know if you want to see
someone before then just don't be super
bait about it I think women tend to move
on quicker than men anyway but
um yeah I'd say about a year if you're
doing something there just try and keep
it under wraps a little bit I'll say
five to seven working days
do you know you know it is here like
women this is what I kind of read about
women women will go through this
emotional transition straight away and
kind of get over it and you know they'll
have their girls kind of gas them up
away along the way where guys will kind
of Brave it out I didn't mean like six
months down the line and just he just
gets a shot in his chest when he just
remembers like we lost you and it's like
one of those things it kind of hits men
a bit later on yeah but I think um yeah
just get out there man because if you're
gonna spend time thinking about that
person and you know that time is gone
I would say yeah especially if you've
got kids I don't think you should bring
I think when you start distracting
yourself with men when you've got kids
your priority no longer becomes your
kids so I think the priority of post
divorce should be their well-being and
that should take a year for both of them
they need to adapt and adjust so if
you're out there meeting new men
immediately your kids are suffering and
I don't think that's a good look yeah
actually what's the marriage situation
because she's right because it's
different if you've got kids and if you
don't have kids for with kids
what about you guys um yeah I would say
here as well I mean you should give
yourself a break as well to understand
what's going on and you shouldn't just
like com like complete the void of the
previous man with another one or the
woman if that makes sense so give
yourself a break to understand because
he said emotional you know you go
through some emotional Transitions and
all that so you need to give yourself a
break to understand what's going on what
about you I think yes you were like go
go right away because one I feel like if
it's a divorce then it's probably been
like a long time coming so you know I
don't know you probably are in a mental
space where you're already ready to step
out of the relationship but then with
having kids it makes it a bit more
sticky because like yeah you can't
really be bringing random people around
with your kids but you know
you don't have to necessarily even bring
them home or anything I'll go shopping
today I would say as soon as you feel
like it yeah you feel think about how it
broke down and try and fix that about
yourself like what you paid apart in
that yeah and then when you kind of feel
like you're making Headway with it then
get into a relationship but I feel like
oh you are capping with the moving on in
terms of like physically but I think
emotionally like maybe yeah and maybe
you should give it a bit of time after
you've actually figured out what
happened in your last one do you guys
think that women mentally leave before
they break up a relationship I have to
say this I don't want to have guaranteed
sex with you anymore regardless of your
headache too much you are doing way too
much
um so have you guys ever mentally broken
up with someone before you've broken up
with someone yeah yeah so um I'll start
start with you when um how long were you
together
like uh like five four years okay and
mentally when did you break up with him
like when did you know you were gonna
dump him like
oof I I probably like
um okay can I just scrap that one
because that one was actually a really
of a mess on and off one so this one we
were together about like three months
and I knew in two months that I went in
to dump him okay
or the four year one you you don't know
it's like we were on and off throughout
the whole four years okay I don't think
it really counts as oh okay I was just
tummy broke up I was over it after the
first time yeah and then how many times
you get back together
yeah the alpha ghost is that the
alphagos
I was triggered when you said that
I really but what about you
um I would say three months before
breaking up three months what about you
I haven't been in that situation okay
okay what about you guys have you guys
ever done that yeah yeah I had a strike
system
she didn't even last two weeks and you
know what it's not it's not about her
though like that's just my bad vetting
stage in it like I had a terrible
vetting process at that time and so
because she didn't last for two weeks so
I think that's more to do with me were
you dating her in two weeks no I was
dating up for a little while and then
she's like yo I'ma do these things when
you get serious so I'm like cool let's
see that and um yeah two weeks which
just went quick it was like you know
when yeah three strikes what did she do
I'll give you I'll give you I'll give
you one I'll give you one
um
uh
she just did she just disrespected
herself on online oh okay I'll put it
that way I don't want to get into it oh
yeah
something in that atmosphere
all right she did that three times no no
no no no no no the same week you know
it's like some some people's behaviors
might be triggers for you to act out our
character or mess up your Vibes and your
energy and all that kind of stuff so if
someone's showing you that they don't
respect you like that they just listen
to the minute so we don't like I'm gonna
sit here and have a a big folder full of
um red flags I'll just have three and
then I'll just cut it off I actually had
to fold it though
yeah
a folder a folder like a screenshot a
screenshot yeah you know what happens
what happens
did you share the album at the end
this is the reason B no like um what it
is is sometimes you'll get lost in the
sauce so you'll forget about how bad the
nonsense one to ten how much was cool
she was cool she had a lot of great
quality but it was just a little bit I
met like how good though
she was nice she was attractive I
thought anyone one to ten she was she
was above a seven not Seven Ten not by
eight yeah okay okay
um do you feel like you give girls more
wiggle room if they're if they're hotter
yes
you have do you know it is you have to
be real with yourself though like you
gotta you gotta look yourself in the
mirror so if someone's taking a piss you
go be like come on man and I think
that's why people say it's ego but
that's where you gotta kind of release
say to yourself that's why if you set
yourself like those morals and those
ground rules for yourself then no matter
who steps in front of you if they
disrespect you then they've disrespect
you you gotta kind of hold yourself
accountable today but do they get away
with a bit more be honest uh than if she
was average if if it's black and white
then no no I mean okay so every guy
what's like every guy has an attraction
floor so I don't I don't know wait let's
let's say seven is yours so for girls
that one girl's a seven and one's a nine
are you giving the nine more wiggle room
I'm gonna give it a nine more wiggle
room yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
wait what's what's up it's like the out
the sauce
okay okay so it's more to do with that
than just looks alone that's toxic
that's toxic relationships for you yeah
you know honestly
um do you think like like a nine gives
it better than that seven because I
personally think sevens give it way
better than the night
do they feel like they have to work
harder
maybe maybe I feel like the prettier you
are the less you kind of do in bed
because the ones that aren't as great as
the rest that they work they work it's
gym Antics we go into the night Supply I
think it's more to do with how crazy she
is is it how crazy or how beautiful she
is determined well that determines what
her passion yeah that's what they
usually say it's more to do with her
instability crazy in the real world is
linked to passionate in that world so
more to do with looks it's more
instability unstable women tend to be
more passionate it's the roller coaster
of emotions that they face yeah if you
get if you are an in like I'm an intense
person and so I've had intense
relationships prior you know so and
that's based on how you make them feel
like you've described as well but also
if they're a little bit crazy like but
in
intense relationships and toxic
relationships they're lit but obviously
they're not sustained they're not
sustainable yeah unsustainable I mean
like when you wake up and there's like
someone standing over with a knife you
just I go aggravated
has that happened to you yeah yeah but
it was a different girl who tried to
push me downstairs
yeah but I'm like you're like five foot
you need to check
yeah this is crazy yeah they like to
make up for one if guys the short man
syndrome is the same thing
okay okay let's just break this down so
so wait wait you woke up and she had a
knife yeah yeah yeah a why yeah everyone
says that what do I do I don't do what
should you do I'm just kidding what did
you do I don't know
probably to be honest I probably
aggravated her like I was but the thing
is I used to be a Savage I'm not you
know respectful Mad Men like that how
angry she was is that what's the reason
did you call the police no no I actually
just said look you were you doing you're
gonna make me a sandwich with that yeah
but to be fairly you know what is I I
don't I will say this though I haven't
um I used to not be a very self-aware so
I used to do things and then see why
someone would get upset and think what's
that problem upset that she will
actually hold it nice yeah but I'm like
I'm like I just think oh she's just
being crazy but yeah but now you know
your own red flags yeah but when you
start analyzing it and she's crazy I'm
sorry there's no excuse me no exactly
that's what that is your character
beforehand as well yeah there's no
excuse for them I mean but you sometimes
I think it's good to take account you
couldn't you can like drive people to
things you don't realize what you're
doing I think you can make people crazy
I think you can and like when you look
back
crazy but that is way too much holding a
knife that's extreme
I think you have to have it in them but
you as a person can definitely a good
night the west side of a human being
good like that yeah I agree I think
you're either either crazy or you're not
and you either have it in you or you
don't like there's a baseline I've been
in toxic I've been in a toxic situation
where I very well could have acted crazy
but that's not my character I wouldn't
do that so you're either the type of
person to do that [ __ ] or you're not I
don't basically but the way I have girls
ever brought the worst in you because I
know I've done it and I'm like before I
get into it before I get into any
situation I have a look at myself and I
say listen if it gets Peak I'm walking
the best thing to do I'm so grounded
like that but that's yeah
all the time there's no there's nothing
you can't you need to look at it like
this here before I met you you uh if I
met you're just an attractive woman and
then we got together and the feelings
grew and all this kind of stuff but I
don't need you in my life I didn't need
you before so I can still live without
it gee I mean so um yeah I'd love to
have that have that talk with yourself
though because otherwise you get lost in
the sauce and it's crazy and you might
do something stupid and then you might
be in jail or something like that and
she's moving on anyway it's done for
real you might you might be in jail yeah
it gets slower some situations man there
was there was a an interesting scenario
though when I quote someone with their
thumb trying to put my thumb
you know in those moments I'm not even
angry I'm just it's just you must be so
embarrassed exactly
you said that's standard
but it's going through phone standard I
don't think
they always try to Snoop and sometimes I
mean sometimes you can get baited out
but whatever yeah um yeah they always
have that inkling as well and if if they
there's nothing worse than a woman's
intuition she might not have any
evidence but her intuition is enough so
then she goes looking for the evidence
if you had a business you would do
audits right yeah okay it's only this
whole it's the notion of a man you know
caring so much to look through but I
think I would say like this if you felt
like he was gonna you was with her for a
while and you weren't really and you
felt like something was is up
I understand why certain men do
personally I wouldn't just because I
don't even want to feel what's on that
side so if I feel something's up I just
walk I'm just like that now yeah but um
sometimes sometimes not that deep
especially like when you feel something
like really feel something for it you
might be thinking you know let me not
make the crazy part let me just see if
it's actually if it's not then babe I'm
sorry but then when you do because I've
been in that situation I actually came
across what I thought it was you do end
up going on the crazy side of it because
you end up feeding into what what you
originally thought yeah because deeply
like you could have found nothing and
you almost feel like Colombo you're like
yes I found something but then you've
got that you got that energy
now what like we're gonna do now and the
thing is if you find something if you do
look and you find something don't just
nag them like leaving it do something
yeah just you know I mean you wanna you
wanna keep the person around and then
just punish them I think modern women I
think they like being cheated on I swear
to God because the amount of girls
yeah because they never yeah but then
you could say about Modern Men because
they like the baddest [ __ ] I mean I
don't see it's interesting you know
what's interesting especially with you
and like other girls that come on the
show whenever we talk about women like
they always have to say but men because
it's interesting
we don't we don't go into the women's
conversation and say and to the women's
conversation and say but men but why
don't we just say but people but people
why is it so Divine because this is my
podcast
but like it's like kind of like
entitlement you want to come on here and
tell me how to run my podcast and how to
run the conversation right it's not the
case but isn't it I know but sometimes
you can make a statement about women
without saying but men the same way we
could State make a statement about men
without saying but women
I think the genders the genders are
different there's different things but
when that when something applies to both
genders like men being cheated on women
and now we know that men and women so
why wouldn't we say people these days
prefer because they choose women cheat
more so what does that tell you about
Modern Men they're choosing cheating
women so why are we
yeah
biologically predisposition to be
repulsed by women if women are cheating
more what does that tell you she's
getting with men right not choosing
cheating women yeah because they may not
staying with that woman but should I
choosing cheating women we said that
they're not true not for a relationships
and then how can women are cheating more
how are they cheating more if I'm not
chosen I can't cheat on anyone yeah but
so I'm being chosen women get away with
cheating more well I'm always sleepy if
we're being Chosen
and even when you're chosen married
women as much as married okay this is
all right this is my point yeah so my
point actually is so you're kind of
derailing the combo so not not even
talking about this the reason I think
why do women like to be cheated on is
because they catch him cheating they
never leave and I've had girl after girl
after girl after girl and sometimes they
do but whenever I ask when did you leave
it's never when they catch him cheating
it's like when he stops it's like it's
too late now it's like no no it's like
they cheat they catch them and then six
months later then you leave what yeah
you could have you could have left when
he was cheating so so in my head it's
like when he's cheating when she has
actual evidence of him cheating she
stays when she has no evidence of him
cheating she leaves so modern women like
to be cheated on that's my point Modern
Men I've never heard men say oh I was
cheated on and I stay because they don't
admit it I'm a therapist I work with men
who just stay with cheating women you
don't work and be around that but if you
are around it you see men all the time
saying I got with this guy I know she
was a bit loose she had her pictures out
on Instagram I know she slept with one
of the guys I knew but I still loved her
I got married at you're selecting cheers
as well
why did they stay that's why
the whole point the whole point is like
when he's cheating she's staying when he
stops she leaves the men don't men don't
typically leave relationships women
leave 90 of the time if they're college
educated they're not likely to leave
even if a woman's cheating in marriages
they're more likely to stay because
let me take half of your assets up to 70
in the UK and your kids I mean it's not
like they want it's not what they do the
governments the government's making them
stay they have to stay they have no
choice yeah but they they pick cheats
but you agree with that right yeah yeah
do you have a truth especially when
you've got kids because then you lose
kids with women when we leave we don't
lose our kids you lose your kids but I
do think that men pick cheaters as well
because you'll see the girls who've got
clear red flags that I'm gonna cheat her
bodies out on Instagram she's lots of
guys know her whatever it is they're the
girls that get the most attention and if
you didn't want a cheating woman you
wouldn't cheat
relationship yeah but where does you
said where does relationship starts
through sex you said that earlier in
your cupboard because they started
sex but who wish women would make it to
the final rounds not the Unfaithful ones
you'd be not not for the men with the
options I agree they're a desperate set
there's a synth epidemic yes there is a
Sims epidemic yeah but the men the men
that have the choice I don't think they
pick cheaters men that have the choice I
do but Alpha men like I was saying in
the alpha men don't pick cheaters not at
all but the majority of men aren't Alpha
and they choose who's beautiful you're
saying she is like it's a blood type
someone someone can be in a situation
and they just get lost in the sauce and
they [ __ ] up or they choose to go and
cheat it's not it's not like a oh this
person is a cheater that person there
are definite signs but someone has to
cheat First Once at least I mean so
before they cheated the whole the whole
point is that when he's cheating she
stays when he's not cheating she goes
like I don't I don't see the same thing
for men where when she's cheating he
stays when she's not cheating he goes
yeah yeah but I do but it doesn't add up
statistically if you're saying women
file for divorce more and women cheat
more that tells us that women are being
selected more and they're the ones
choosing to leave so men aren't leaving
cheaters and they're choosing them
that doesn't add up statistics say that
again so if women are more likely to
divorce a man and women are more likely
to cheat that shows us that men are more
likely to stay with cheaters women are
the ones exited there's a simple
epidemic that's absolutely statistics I
think also maybe the the women aren't
cheating first
maybe because I think you know the woman
will stay with the man that's cheated
for a little while and then she'll find
you know the jujitsu guy or the best
friend or the Cassie and Diddy kind of
situation yeah that's true and then that
that betrayal is so much that he just
you know I mean yeah maybe they're not
cheating first they're not cheating
anymore
no I think that it's like the women I
mean I think it's mostly like the girls
settle with the like the beta guy or the
guy she didn't really well I mean I want
to say subtle it's really her level but
she settles with the guy she doesn't
want and then cheats with the guy she
does
[Music]
I can't speak on that do you think I I
don't I wouldn't be able to I've never
been with this teacher
I don't know what I'd be honest I don't
cheat I don't know what that Vibe what
it is
um so I can't really speak on it but I
do think you know when a girl's able to
cheat just like when you know with a man
I disagree you know I swear to God
there's this girl oh my god I've told
the story on my on my podcast before I
don't think you know there's a girl on
my on my
and be careful sometimes you'll be
finding these people there's a girl on I
was on three different teams so there's
a girl on a team I was on in college
yeah and literally she was a girl next
door you would never know she seemed
like the sweetest chick and I swear to
God she had a a guy she dated her
freshman year of college did him for a
month he cheated he was like all around
town or whatever her senior year
um she was with a guy that bought her
bought her a house she moved in and I
was like yeah yeah I've told it before
and I was at a party and literally like
her and her body wasn't on Instagram she
was a school teacher good with kids
sweet nice like and literally she was in
the bathroom with the guy from freshman
year at the party her boyfriend came to
um
he bought her a house he bought her
exactly she doesn't respect him and that
was kind of a red pill moment for me
where I was like God damn you would
never know yeah and I also maybe because
I live in Dubai and I see a lot where
these men are setting the women up
they're getting them nannies getting
them drivers and they're using that
spare time and his money to go on dates
with their boyfriend friend and that's
where I think the cheating on the
women's side is so much worse because
she's doing it on his clock and on his
money I've seen it firsthand that it's
like with his car they're going out too
that's simple though yeah like but
they're okay with it because they they
want to cheat as well so there's like as
long as there is a lot of people there's
a lot of open marriages in Hollywood and
stuff so do you think it's just the way
forward sadly what both people cheating
of course I think it's just it's
different it's different it's not I
think everyone says we're cheating and
and stuff like this in general it's just
like everything's the same
the men can cheat so therefore women can
cheat and women and men cheat the same
way and we just cheat as much it's all
nonsense and it's completely different
sure both sexes cheat both genders cheat
whatever but the men are doing it for a
different reason to the women aren't the
women are doing it from different ways I
mean I think as a woman if you're if you
have an Instagram that's open and you
got like like sexual pictures I think
that's cheating yeah
and they pick that girl
I think that's worse
I'm Caribbean I've never seen like one
CFC we have our Carnival yeah so our
costumes as you know they are very
revealing so me personally like I had
this conversation about guys many many
years ago that my ex I'll see it through
was my guy by my ex she would dress up
in the most when it comes Carnival and
all you really see is is a little little
brother that covers a nipple because I'm
the covers of Taunton and big old
feathers now me personally not her
Instagram
I don't mind any attack to me I don't
see that as being cheating because I'm
okay with it it's only cheating if you
as your spouse is not okay with it and
you're still doing it against it
you don't think that's an invitation was
she advertising she could advertise they
won't touching it so catching my only
friends
yeah we breaking all the plants together
your definition is because the
definition of cheating is there has to
be some level of sexual intimacy and
there has to be some level of secrecy if
there's no secrecy then it's not
cheating so I think he's right yeah so
if you're in an open relationship it's
not cheating
I think accepting I mean look if if
you're in if you're in a relationship
and you know you're with a guy that says
it's okay you know it's kind of the same
thing as like being with a woman or like
with a guy that's like a woman that says
it's okay to sleep with other girl like
but I just think attention is currency
to women and you're like accepting
attention from other men like I just
that's disrespectful that notion is
disrespectful no because it's how you
receive this how they receive it is only
a matter of time before somebody that is
giving the attention is someone that she
wants to reciprocate the attention to
it's only a matter of time is supposed
to come into it
you're supposed to put borders around
and boundaries around to limit the
environment so this culturally that's
normal for myself we act about if I can
go to a club and wine and Chuck up on 15
20 guys knowing that yeah but I'm not
taking No Instagram no numbers no no and
I'm going home to my account and I'm
still cutting up in bed and speaking
with us when when the snipers are out
and they're looking for women that are
in relationships they're like they think
oh cool yeah this girl probably chew on
a man what do you guys think are the are
the telling signals and one of them is
like revealing themselves in a certain
kind of way because it makes sense
because I look at the women that are
happy in their relationships and they
don't do this they don't even post
exactly yeah that's disrespect why would
you still post revealing pictures if
you're already in them you don't really
want to go out like that when you're in
a happy room exactly that's what I mean
as a girl anyways what you disagree
there what do you think
it's not a prison a relationship I think
oh yeah yeah so I feel like the
boundaries of having to not post what
you want on your Instagram that sounds
quite like a prison
because it's that is yeah
what's going on I have a question would
you give up your social media for a guy
if he said I'm not comfortable with it
um
or would you mind if he was liking
thirst traps like or is that putting
boundaries on him and that's prison oh
see yeah even that I think it's weird I
think if he was coming I think guys that
don't like when their girl posts it's
weird I feel like when girls don't like
when their guy likes other girls
pictures
I feel like those are like really it's
about two serious boundaries like it
depends like you can't be careful like
you can't be like the girls that don't
like it you the guy then call me dumb
like you can't be hypocrite with the
situation if one's open with it I feel
like that one should be open to a
certain degree as well no I'm yeah I'm
saying they're both weird listening
great girlfriend it also does depend on
what their point you're saying about or
whenever they post it's about what they
post that's the issue that's the thing
it's the content yeah
this is a reflection of like like your
thought process maybe your style
whatever
um it's it doesn't necessarily mean it's
an invitation for people say about your
style it just says you've got a good
[ __ ] butt
okay I'm gonna take a second to read
Super Chat um guys um blessing one to
monopod did I say it right a monopod
yeah so I'm also the top Super chatter
today get um we're gonna send you am I
gonna sign like a hat or something
autograph I don't know I'm signing
something and it will be sent to you um
allegedly
um okay so Clifford range imagine buying
a new car but the salesman tells you
that they want to keep a for sale sign
in the front window that's Instagram
[Music]
um Doug MPA bro in the back is the king
of simp
um 90 Frito pie relationships are from
God this is why we fail them um Jacob
Mackenzie the girl's argument makes no
sense by definition you must be chosen
to cheat in the first place so girls are
either single or they cheat therapists
are always nuts 90 free toe pay what's
your girl's insta hot guy simp I'm 90
free Tope YouTube sensors hard is there
another way to chat
um I probably can add cash up or
something next show I'll look into it
Jared Braggs um men on mass aren't
picking cheat men cap men on mass aren't
picking cheating women 90 free-toe pie
domestic violence has not justified It
Hat dude equals simp marriage causes
divorce all the research shows women get
over divorced quicker as they have been
planning it whereas the men lose
everything like money house and the kids
um NSX if you were a broke Chad but high
energy and seem smart and ambitious she
will bed you in hopes that to help you
succeed and earn a bag you got three
months can extend if you show progress
Times short true for ninety percent of
women
90 free-toe pie name a funny woman 90
Frito pie your toner is off get better
at speaking Miss K 93 toe pie if you had
no if you had no oh [ __ ] then what
leverage would you have Doug MPA
um discount Kim K needs to realize that
men's match nines and tens but Mary's
sixes and sevens nines and tens are too
much maintenance and will always take up
too much energy Russell Warren thanks
for the discussion I appreciate it I'm
Edgar Reyes my great grandpa had a wife
and he had five other women my grandpa
had another woman across town double
standard maybe an SX if a man walks away
from his career chances chances increase
she will lose interest if he wants a
career back after 12 months he is likely
disadvantaged by three-year careers
men's shoes career please I'm gonna
refresh it really quick just to make
sure there are no other ones guys like
the video um there are over 2000 people
watching live so I think we should have
at least 2 000 likes
um
okay spent spencil Caribbean what this
man is saying is Cap if he cared about
his woman he wouldn't be happy for her
just to be out there like that he is
just a pimp
um PJ Cornell just travel and find
non-western women Clifford range I read
that one okay
um okay so I was gonna show this earlier
let me pull it up
what percent
of NBA players do you think get divorced
after retirement
90 yeah I'm gonna say that majority a
minute
because they pull up with that [ __ ] and
now it's like are you broke okay
what do you guys think I think it would
be high but I think it's more for the
fact that the women were used to them
not being around so much and they didn't
realize that they had so much conflict
until they spend so much time together
and then they divorce yeah I agree yeah
so what person do you think it has
nothing to do with the money
what percent
I know what percent get divorced do you
think a very high like 70 75 75 yeah I
would say about 17. what do you think
I think maybe like 50.
87 percent
of course let me and I think it's within
a couple years damn
that is way too high they're not in the
purpose so he's not even making his
money anymore and he still takes off
she's crazy
and she can cheat on him and still take
his half his money isn't that crazy
she gets caught cheating
that's good these guys invest in ring
for your door
it says 16 of NFL players drafted
between 1996 and 2003 declared
bankruptcy within 12 years of retirement
remind us in the woman remember the
lifestyle the men lead is hectic do you
think women marry a lifestyle yes yes
what do you guys think yes oh yeah I
think smart women do I think they do but
it doesn't lifestyle doesn't mean have
to be doing up holidays it can be I just
want to be married with kids and I just
want to stay home and I don't want to be
working all the time or I want to get
pregnant that's also lifestyle so yeah
they definitely married for a change
they want to change whatever life
they're living I think potential plays a
huge part in it her
uh her ability to see the potential on a
man will determine what kind of
Lifestyle you have um
what percent of American football
players get divorced do you think
that's high as well slowly I feel like
maybe they're women stay like I was
watching a program on the NFL lot and a
lot of them have like homegrown women
like homegrown women
childhood sweetheart type yeah yeah so
maybe a lesser percent like maybe
something like 70. but they also got
like
injuries and stuff like that so it's
it's um yeah and they're really volatile
and yeah yeah I mean yeah that's Ticky
I'll give it a seven year yeah same I'd
say about 75. you guys are good 60 to 80
that's what they argue
billionaires have the lowest rates of
divorce and highest rates of marriages
maybe because they have the most to lose
but it's also like billionaires just
don't get
divorcedure yeah they take off he makes
another 100 billion later on they've got
the highest rate of marriage they're
like 87 of billionaires are married and
they've got the lowest rate of divorce
well I think it's because
um
they stay married for a legacy where
where
um people that like get money quick
often lose it quick and they usually
also come from Rich families and so they
grew up in for a parent like that kind
of Lifestyle whereas people who get rich
through Sports and music they don't
usually come from stable homes always
well I just think of like the gates like
Bill Gates Hillary Clinton or um
um Hillary like sorry not the gate sorry
the clintons the gates got divorced the
clintons how they stayed married even
through everything but I don't even
think they like each other exactly
that's like a legacy thing yeah yeah
well what do you see respect and
everything you know reputation talking
about all of these factors Legacy what
do you what do you guys think about like
um Nick Cannon
um
because you can't invest in each child
equally when they're from sporadic homes
financially but you can't emotionally be
available yeah but even if you had one
household with
um 12 kids yeah have you seen cheaper
about a dozen no but it sounds bad news
going missing you know I mean at least I
would say this right if you if you
divided the kids up amongst different
households yeah they would get more
attention from their mother at least a
good point when you think about it
because I was one in ten we didn't see
my dad a Tony who's gone a lot yeah I
know but you know there's some knowledge
of that he's gonna come home whereas
with when you're sporadic it's like Dad
might not come here
you might say listen every Sunday we're
gonna round everybody up and we're gonna
you know yeah
yeah because in all of history it's been
multiple well it's that like 8 000 years
ago 17 men reproduced for every one man
it's not like the men were the like the
kids were fine but they would all be in
one home and when you have separate
homes you also open up the doors for
other men entering the home with your
children and child abuse increases are
you sure yeah 100 child abuse is highest
yeah
100
I wasn't talking about that part I was
part that they were there because like
in the old days like men had to go off
for months no I think they would all be
in one home he'd have to provide for one
home one household it wouldn't be for
ten different women in 10 different
Villages that one just doesn't that one
just doesn't benefit the women
that you know nikana's ideology just
doesn't really it doesn't benefit the
children because you're opening them up
to step parents
me if I if I woke up yeah one day and I
realized that I got a brother I didn't
know about and did it and I got this
whole big family enough who I was the
only child I'm not going to be upset
or if your mom had entered a stepfather
who was abusive to you throughout your
life
what are you talking about when you when
you have lots of like 10 different baby
mums you're opening the door up for step
parenting step parenting is linked to
more of child abuse and home neglect
even if not abuse neglect because they
start a new family and the child always
feels like an outside looking in so
that's on the women though I don't even
think that's on the man that's seven
that's 17 irresponsible woman that's one
irresponsible man yeah if anything I
think that shows that women would rather
share a successful the guy than have
than keep a guy that they actually would
be faithful to them I think guys are
going to start doing that when they
reach a certain plateau of success it's
they said that Tate has like I just saw
something online like that he has like
10 kids if you believe that I'm not
surprised he hasn't denied kids he says
I wouldn't come on here and say I had
kids but he doesn't actually say he
doesn't have kids or maybe you know his
smart mind is probably keeping them out
the lighting yeah yeah
yeah would you want lots of different
mothers for your children
I would like you know if I wanted a big
family then I wouldn't be against it I
don't necessarily want a huge huge fan
because I've got a lot of brothers and
sisters anyway oh you can't have seven
seven kids to one woman now that's a lot
man am I even gonna want that pumpkin
I'm not joking about this
would you ideally like one baby mother
or several ideally
uh one wife or maybe a mother of a child
like you and your children would you
like them to come from one moment or
several and I said like if for three
yeah I think three is manageable in one
home
so three in one home and then like two
and then if I wanted ten then I'd split
them out I would I would speak to them
and be open and say all right cool let's
let's give you a rest
but yeah that's his rotation yeah
what would you guys do
yeah I know but I wouldn't like I well
like I like my
um my my grandfather he has loads of
kids like 15 kids and stuff so
um I've me personally part of the reason
I got mad I didn't really want to do all
that I wanted to have kids when I was
married I didn't want all this just like
kids everywhere or whatever
um I just think negative because
ultimately like when the father's
removed there's this problems so I've
always wanted to to be married and have
kids within marriage and it's just
better for the kids in general so that's
my party no I agree with that too yeah
it's it's interesting because I see both
sides because like on one hand that was
so common in all of history
you know what's interesting that men
can't marry multiple like I don't know
here can they legally marry more than
one person no that's a Christian country
but it's interesting because they could
still be baby mamas so it's like they
might as well get the legal benefits I
don't really like I wouldn't go that
route so it doesn't affect me but it's
just interesting how one is one is paid
and one kid
I mean they get paid you know CSA how
does that work if you've got loads of
kids low different families it's a
certain amount split up between I just
know in the UK you you get a cert you
get I don't know if they still do it but
at one point you got free housing if you
had a kid and you're incentivized like
if there's you get more either money
from the government or child support if
you have multiple dads who are actually
incentivize yeah they actually like pay
you to have multiple baby mothers
but she even said that like people would
want to move out of their parents house
so they would have a kid back in her day
yeah and again they would give them a
flat and stuff if they got there
I mean you've got to do like about a
couple weeks at the YMCA but after that
just move Salem wow I'm curious so you
you know a decent amount do you know
um like how the law is disadvantage men
when it comes to marriage you seem to be
familiar yeah if you were a man would
you man would you get married today
um if I wasn't religious like if I had
no religion no no I would never get
married I wouldn't get married at all
with religion I always say I would need
to because it wouldn't be a marriage if
it wasn't ordained by God but if I
didn't have any religious but I still
don't understand why people who aren't
really just get married men or women I
don't understand why non-religious
people get married I don't understand it
at all where you don't believe in God
and you don't I think it needs to be
anything spiritual but you're then
getting married in a church it really
confuses me what makes marriage useful
to a non-religious person I'm I'm
actually curious what is it it's the
social status I think yeah I don't agree
with that well I don't agree with a
social status at all what are you
religious uh I've been brought up
religious but I'm not actively religious
what made you want to get married
um yeah to be honest it had it didn't
really have a lot to do with religion
but um I think it's more to do with
Traditions rather than than religion so
she isn't religious but her family is
Muslim so
um just just having babies just isn't
really a thing and it's the same in my
family we just don't have babies for
jokes so we're like his sister he said
if you are gonna you know commit to
someone you should commit to them
properly right you know it might not
work and all the rest of it and divorce
and all these other things but the
intention is that yeah yeah yeah I think
that I can't just I personally just
wouldn't feel comfortable having just
kids with loads of different women and I
think that negatively affects the kids a
lot let me ask you this you know um I'm
sure your marriage is is going smoothly
if for whatever reason it didn't and you
got divorced would you be opposed to
having any more kids
foreign
interesting I don't like the idea of
like uh the
uh like I know someone for example when
they were married and now and they have
kids together and now they've broke up
or whatever divorced and um he's gone to
like start another family and I
understand it because of his age but I
think that
I don't know I don't know I I don't know
maybe if the future because maybe that
will do that's why I wouldn't get mad
again I wouldn't get mad that's how I
kind of that's how I kind of look at the
Nick Cannon thing because you think all
right yeah 12 is a bit extreme or
whatever and obviously he's got like his
health underlying conditions which might
play a uh into it but if you were in a
situation and you gave you all you got
married you've done it the right way X Y
and Z and you still and you got it just
didn't work out yeah while you were
still young and then you get with
someone new love of your life and you
thought cool and she ain't got no kids
and she wanted kids you that you know I
mean it can happen like that you can go
the whole way so unless that means he's
doing it purely yeah and that's even
worse because then you're doing it
purely for somebody else you don't want
it that's no different to having an
abortion yeah would you be against the
kids but Nick Cannon don't you think
it's weird that he's just submitting to
every woman you get dates yeah you know
it'd be interesting I'm just thinking it
would be interesting to see because I
would imagine what most of the one
parent household data is like what one
parent isn't involved in their life so
it'd be really into interesting to see
what the data would say for like because
I think Nick Cannon is involved in all
of his kids lives so it would just be
interesting
I wouldn't recommend that yeah you know
but again I just have a hard time
telling the world how to be and
throughout all of history it's been
multiple women for a small select group
of men so I just I'm not one to tell the
world how to be it just is what it is I
wonder how Mariah Carey feels about his
behaviors because she's like I don't
understand why people will say that it's
like like respectfully it's none of her
business but it's just a uh yeah it
can't deny her stasis and then being
associated with a bunch of baby mamas it
must be feeling away like she went from
him to a billionaire that she was
engaged in he went from her to a bunch
of baby mamas I don't think it's gay
did she get married no I think she ended
up marrying getting with her dancer her
backup dancer or something like that
yeah
wow that's interesting it's the same
yeah so she got engaged to the
billionaire with a background answer oh
my God
it's a real thing when are we going to
stop looking up to like celebrity
couples yeah please we're at the point
when they stop influencing the point is
that celebrity couples show what goes on
in the real in real Society because when
you see it like okay let's take let's
take Johnny Depp and Amber Heard you
know you could say oh that's a celebrity
couple that's toxic but if that happened
to a money with a man with power money
and Status what happens to the average
guy like maybe the guy getting cheated
on maybe he just makes 80k a year 70k
you're like he doesn't have have as much
money but the point is like the girl
will still cheat with your with her
personal trainer and his like and
hitting I think that was good it
highlighted how many women hit men yeah
yeah the hitting was really bad in that
yeah yeah okay and the other thing is he
could only defend himself because of who
he is yeah that happens like you're
saying to Everyday guys yeah that's yeah
like I've had I've done so many
interviews with people where it's like
the girl abused me for you oh my gosh I
had this one guy he was so sad he told
me the story where this girl was abusing
him for years and like nobody believed
him
and then it was like he finally left and
then he was the bad guy like his whole
friend group like painted him out to be
that the worst person ever
yeah I had another guy he she was
abusing him like um and then she left
and took half and took the kids that's
so horrible that can happen even when
she cheats
and then I guess women like women will
always say why did she cheat what do you
mean why did she cheat
[Music]
anyone who's single if we're just
thinking [ __ ] relationships
that's why I'm against the division side
of things because it puts
it puts you on a good Society we should
actually teach people how to be good
with each other rather than point out I
mean I just think that's the feminine
point of view but it's like from
like guys have had to see media saying
men are trash for years and then it's
like whenever we have a conversation
about what the women are doing the women
have to come in and say oh but it's not
all women but this this and this like
what about men what about men but it's
like we've had the conversation about
men for years I mean we had I don't got
no scrubs like that was on that was a
front I know but we also had I get
[ __ ] in the club and this that and
the other and we've had that
you know you know that's a little
disingenuous though because you know
it's not the same you know you know it's
slanted towards the feminist I'm not
like a oh anti-man or anything like that
but I am anti both red pill and the
feminists will come be an anti-men
because it is
just the study of human behavior red
bullies anti-women no it's not anti
because even if I have if you read the
comments left by red pill men it can
never be a rational debate it will never
be like I disagree with this it's like
tell her where's her makeup from where's
her and it's like so angry where you
can't have rational conversations with
red pill men you can I'll watch these
comments today
that sounds like a you problem because I
have rational conversations
my conversations with red pill men and
if they were anytime you know stop
interrupting me stop interrupting me and
if they were anti-misogynistic then I
would have an issue but they're not but
you you say that you speak their
language very few men will say Paul
where's your ring
wrong wrong I was just on an interview
yeah I was grilled for two hours
straight by a freaking blue pill betta
song I'm talking about red pills listen
listen to me what I'm saying I've had
conversation with red pill guy
anti-marriage guy anti this this this
this guy never had an issue the only
issue I've ever had and and got grilled
on this that stuff was by a blue pill
dude exactly what my point is Redfield
men will never come for you because you
speak their language but if you try and
tell them rational debates and give them
logical answers that aren't regurgitated
Kevin Samuel videos or anything they'll
come for you they really will and that's
right that's not true because when I
started I wasn't red pill
I have two years I have I have two years
worth of videos the first time I watched
canvan Samuels I did not say nice things
about I was not a fan and I never had
issues with misogyny I never had issues
with like women haters I just said the
only thing that they debate is ideas I
mean I mean they might troll you a
little bit if anything but you won't
experience it because you don't speak no
and opposite language you're not
listening to what I'm saying when I
started on YouTube
I did not agree with everything I had
many I I
said twenty thousand twenty thousand now
you're on I have more now what's your
point but you keep moving the goal post
because you said you speak their
language I said when I didn't speak
their language I had no issue so it's a
you problem because even even when I
when I did not speak their language I
had no issues uh well I can speak from
my experience when I say any video that
agrees with men like if I say women
shouldn't dress like this or feminism is
this I'll get the men raving reposting
moment you call them out and say no no
also men need to do this just to create
a rational balance dialogue they turn
into the male equivalent of feminists
where they lose all their rationality
and become emotional and they'll start
making personal remarks the exact same
thing they accuse women of doing they go
to being personal when they don't have a
lot of logical argument does the comment
section roast yeah yeah but it doesn't
bother me that they Rose me they can say
whatever they want but the reality is it
only happens when I don't talk their
language and they display the same
emotional dysregulation as a feminist
they claim to hate the feminists that
say I hate women all men are trash the
red pill men when you don't speak their
language it displayed the exact level of
femininity irrationality and personal
remarks that we are always told that
women do I mean I just think it's silly
to go on the internet and not expect to
get bad comments so so on both sides
yeah on both sides so it's like did you
get hate comments does that does that
mean the whole red pill movement when
I've when I I'm the one who knows all of
the people that lead the space I'm the
one who's met them you're basing your
experience off of the comment section no
I'm basing it off the red pill community
that I see and what I find okay have you
met any of them in person other than me
so I'm saying with the red pill men that
you that you're talking about have you
met any yeah I've met any any any
content creators no content creators I
could get in contact with a few but
online and stuff but not in person
because they're usually American okay so
so you haven't even dealt with them and
you're making an assumption about them
but I can make an assumption based on
like you haven't dealt with feminists or
whales or [ __ ] that but you can make an
assumption because they come for you
right I can make an assumption based on
the ones I've talked to in real life
where I was attacked but I've never I've
never communicated with feminists but
I've had feminists contact my workplace
and then try and get me fired I've had
feminists that have come from my parents
photo phone numbers and address so I can
make an assumption on them even though I
haven't met them in real time because I
live I've never met a feminist no I'm a
feminist yeah you met me and yeah but I
could still make assumptions on the
extremities of both red pill and
feminism because I experienced both of
them in real life but I've had my job
contacted I've had my boss call me me
and say this we've been sent this I've
had feminist posts repost my videos it's
like a crazy person rather than like a
person that has but the extremities on
each end are as bad as each other it's
as bad as each other red pill men are
the male equivalent of feminists when
they go to that extreme because what
happens with both of them is that they
forget to incorporate their own
experiences and they just have this
mindset of hate and anger and they're
not even listening to the argument they
just want to show so you're a woman or
don't ask a woman what a man needs don't
ask a woman about outfit no no what
speak rationally have a rational
discourse I mean the the point they're
making about don't ask a woman like what
you're talking about dating advice
General like you can't ask a woman when
the alpha is can't ask what high value
well you can't ask a woman is what what
are you talking about you can ask humans
what humans do yeah I mean you can ask
but
usually they talk about dating advice
like don't take dating advice from women
it's like are you asking the fishermen
that's usually what they're talking
about but then wouldn't that also apply
then don't ask men for men and advice
because you don't ask the fish like
wouldn't that be don't ask men for men
well see no because men have had to
listen to what women have to say for
years women don't have to listen to what
men have to say that's why it's so
triggering a lot of times when I say
things on this podcast like men know
what we want because they've had to
listen to us for the last 20 30 years
um
but I'll be honest um can we Define like
red pill and blue pill because I mean
I'm just thinking like ibuprofen and
Viagra I have no idea
it sounds like
um
people that do you know do you remember
menism it sounds like it's that versus
feminism is it is that right is that is
that no I mean red pill is apraxiology
it's a study of human behavior that's
what it is okay but what is it like
because feminism is equal rights but
really in the real world feminism how
was the how are the masses perceived
yeah right now how is it in real time
what do you mean in real life so I'm
saying is this based off the matrix
it's so [ __ ] everybody loves it I
haven't seen The Matrix I haven't
haven't watched Game of Thrones
but how does the study of like human
behavior correlate to to the like this
topic as in like how does it apply to
dating and advice and all of that what's
the dynamic there
how does it reply to date well so like
gosh there's so much that goes into it
but it's just like women so for example
they study women like and why women do
the things they do so like women look
for different things at different ages
so like for example women one thing they
talk about is a woman's sexual market
value so like when she's at her highest
and what she would look for when she's
the most attractive to men so for
example
women in their early 20s tend to look
for looks well women in their late 20s
to 30s tend to look for security and
that so they would say like these are
the examples and yeah what makes some of
them so triggered where they just spew
out hate and to any woman that has an
opinion I don't know any content
creators that do that um I can't help
the comment section so I think a lot of
people like
I think the difference is like fresh and
Fit I would say Marlon I would say is
very angry because when you speak yeah
no I don't know I don't think so
actually
um I mean he just people don't like his
tone and I think women have an issue
with his tone but no I I don't think he
hates women by any means does he come
across as somebody who has successful
relationships with women and can have a
marriage and a stable relationship with
women yeah I think you could I don't
think he comes across it yeah I mean I
would disagree I mean I don't think they
hate women
um no I don't think that you don't think
he insults the uh like the women's
mindset in general or anything like that
so he might say something like um well
you're 20 once a woman's more than 25
she's got no value and if you haven't
got a ring you haven't got an opinion
women can't Define high value blooming
can't Define Alpha men women don't have
uh can't solve any of men's problems
let me start with the 20th okay you're
giving me a bunch so what was the first
one you said 20 women over 25 yeah they
have no value yeah I mean I don't think
that's misogynistic but no every age has
a cut off so every guy is like
your mom has no value
my mom has no value yeah I've talked to
my mom about this in the sexual
Marketplace nah good luck my mom on the
dating scene
my mom like I love I love you Mom I love
you he's talking about not it's not not
personal words it's sexual market value
so I mean most guys will date a girl for
25 though she looks good true true so
maybe maybe he's pickier he prefer girls
under 25 the point is women under over
the age of 25 typically we've had her
Hearts broken and men have to deal with
that so it's easier to get with a
younger girl who hasn't hasn't had drama
okay do you want do you want to grow
with more trauma or less trauma guy well
I didn't ask you us and then more trauma
or less trauma less trauma more trauma
or less trauma more trauma okay so so so
this is this is as women we listen and
say I understand that instead of trying
to argue and tell you them what they
want yeah and I'm not going to be
offended is my mom gonna do well on The
Dating Market with 10 kids I'm not on
the dating my of course no but I didn't
mean it in sexual I meant in general as
a value as a person but uh I can speak
for somebody when I was 21 and then
going to 25. I genuinely think I did
more reflection and became less
traumatized as I was 10 25. I personally
felt like I was far I was so volatile at
21. I was so impulsive at 21 as I became
old I became less of a burden to a man
but we're not talking about you we're
talking about in general humans yeah
we're more emotional and volatile I'm
saying like in general we're not telling
he doesn't know your specific story so
so if if we're talking to the men and
the men like Andrew Tate said something
similar or women over the age of 2019
and they're and they're saying nothing
he gave the age of 19. and he and if
they're saying we prefer the women
younger yeah why are we to tell them
what they want no no you I think it
should be with a younger woman I really
do think younger is more beautiful and
especially when it comes to having kids
but it's also saying things like oh
women can't Define what makes a man
women have no definition of what makes
an album a biological terms
no the point they're making though is
that like for a man to be Alpha to be
high value he has to be elected by other
men first like other men have to respect
him first before the women can come in
and so that that's that's what they're
talking about is someone disqualified
for realizing or not being able to make
because you can look at a monkey and
decide which one's Alpha you'd have to
be other other men have other high-value
men have to recognize him as a part of
the group so so I mean we're kind of
interchanging high value in Alpha but
but when it comes to high value men
that's what they're talking about yeah
it's the other high value the other no
because of the other high value men have
to recognize him as part of the group
and can a low value man realize a high
value man I think most men when they
walk into a room they can they can just
naturally tell
there's definitely a hierarchy and women
can tell as well they can't as a cap
yeah we can tell when something yeah you
think so
why do you think women and historically
like the the fathers have been involved
women suck at picking men we do I'm
looking I'm not saying I'm better than
any woman like we it you it's always
better to ask your dad or your brothers
about a guy because I'm sorry we're not
good in general my issue is that people
suck up to selecting people because
people tend to be traumatized to
regurgitate their childhood in their
relationships I don't think it's women
who suck because if men didn't suck they
wouldn't have so many problems with
women I I think it's the West I think
it's modern women a lot of men move and
don't have these problems I know a guy
he moved from he moved from America to
Brazil he doesn't have those problems
there it's the West it's amazing it's a
western problem but you can't say women
suck because if men didn't suck at
selecting women they wouldn't happen but
women are the selectors women are the
selectors so it doesn't like you've just
said when it comes to their in women and
selectors they're the ones who are going
to decide if the guys sleep with them or
don't so they are they are select they
are the selectors but it's not about
what you believe because who decides if
you get married the man right right so
if divorces are high what does that tell
you men selecting badly or women are
selecting badly if men decide marriage
but women are leaving the marriages so
they're making the decisions but the
vetting process has to come from them
yeah but they're not divorcing they're
not divorcing uh sorry the women the men
aren't divorce and women the women are
divorcement men like you've said and
that is their decision or to remove
themselves in situation where they've
got everything they can yeah from the
marriage and it's usually based on on
how they feel about the man that doesn't
mean that they're selecting that's
deselecting after they have everything
selected that one I mean but what you
think so on second if you said if you
select a woman you're saying the issue
is that he's made a bad selection and
that's why she's divorce and women no no
no I I said you said that who selected
the woman in the first place that woman
who has now divorced him so you're
saying that because he's picked a bad
woman in the beginning who's who's going
to divorce him eventually it's his fault
is that what you're saying yeah so let's
talk about both sides if we're saying
that women select no no not both sides
are Marx indirectly that particular
situation
if men and women get divorced and women
start I'm just trying to understand and
women
um initiate their divorce
that's the man's fault because they
selected is that right is that the man's
fault it's not the man's fault the women
are paid to leave if you pay someone to
do like men have no say in that that's
why I said it's the West they move they
don't have these problems where else in
the world where else in the world are
men are men moving to get different
wives because the women are so bad
moving to a whole new country do you
think
you would have a happier marriage if you
married someone outside of the West
me personally you guys
I know you are giving that question to
him no no but you cannot but I'm glad
actually I'm glad you get that question
to me because even though my my wife's
western or whatever but she was born in
Egypt and so she's and she's been here
from when she was young so her values
are instilled from when she was younger
in the country that she was born at so
her Western I she hasn't got the same
level of Western ideals and I've always
been like that I've always
um been with women who align with my
morals and values and most of them women
are either their parents are over you
know first generation
um or they've been born there or they've
been born here but their parents have
always been first generation and I split
and been in a successful happy couple
and that's why he's played a huge part
into the selection process do you think
then you made a good selection 100 so do
you think selection matters when men are
choosing women to marry yes
I'm glad we can agree
but I'm not disputed I'm not disputing
I'm just saying that if they've selected
someone no one if you've selected
someone that is the best person that you
could select and based on yourself the
time the options Etc but women change
based on how they feel so they feel
differently you know things can change
up that's why that's why you should
never base your decisions as a as a man
on how she feels because if I let's say
you you made a decision on how you felt
and I went along with it and now your
decision changed the accountability
isn't gonna allow you it's gonna love me
because I should have been man enough to
turn around and be like nah nah that's
great that's how you feel now but that's
not the plan well I did a video that
went quite big and the main thing I said
is mentioned always marry a woman that
loves them more than they love them yeah
and because that's part of the selection
process if she doesn't love you when men
they stay loyal to the cause they can be
have a stay in a marriage that they're
not madly in love with because they see
the bigger picture for women they can't
stay loyal to the course so it's always
important that you pick a woman that
loves you more than you love her you
know what this goes across other boards
as well with men in Lawtey I think we're
sometimes uh you know perceived as oh
we're we're not law almost scumbags etc
etc there's young boys dying in the
street because of loyalty to their
friends and that doesn't doesn't go that
goes to that and it also goes into the
love of a woman so if they if our
loyalty is not the issue any man of like
integrity and loyalty and other men
recognize that going back to the high
value or the alpha or however you want
to describe it these are the kind of key
traits it's not always just about money
loyalty Integrity these are the things
as well loyal to the cause like sticking
with that woman even if you it's not the
same as being faithful unfortunately it
doesn't mean the same thing yeah I agree
I'm gonna go to the same Barber for like
15 years yeah there you go shut up
so what was the next thing you said uh
women uh women can't uh what was the
other things that you were saying um
women think with their feelings so they
always say things like [ __ ] your
feelings but my argument is if we know
women are designed to have more
emotional intelligence we produce more
estrogen we produce more oxytocin we
actually by Design more emotional why
would that be an insult it's like saying
to somebody oh you're disabled [ __ ] your
legs like no you you're designed that
way why is that used as an insult to
women I I mean I think he's just talking
about like a lot of times women think
their feelings are reality so girls on
the girls on the show will come on the
show and say this is like this is how
the world is because of how I feel
basically but that is her reality
because that's how she's designed by
biology that's not what's true so take a
picture so so for so for example we
could talk about the pay Gap women could
feel like we make less than men but he
would say something like [ __ ] your
feelings yeah and so that that's the
context that he's using it in that
context it makes sense because it's page
graph it's just not true but in general
we have innate mechanisms to make us
feel more anxious than a situation is
that's why we're mothers why we get why
we're so good at being mothers is
because we sense danger when it's not
there we think our baby's being left
alone we've got to go we're designed by
that and if we weren't but maybe
governed by our feelings we'd both be
like okay baby the sleep don't need to
check on it but biologically we're
designed to be more feeling based it's
what makes women beautiful which is not
an insult and he uses it as an insult I
don't think he's using it as an insult I
don't think he's just saying it doesn't
work in a debate when you're talking
about that it works in in a discourse if
you're going to communicate to women and
men are going to community to
communicate with women that if they
don't recognize that women exercise
feelings and women don't recognize men
exercise logic they'll never be
compatible you don't have to talk about
it I think he knows that women act
through but okay like this is an example
of you as a woman telling men how they
need to talk to us and it's like they're
trying to do your strategy you're trying
to dictate like how men need to say
things but that's that's not how men do
things
men talk how they talk and so it's like
why would I go to a man and say you have
to talk like a woman like you're
feminism if I'm a man and if I've got a
son as well I know I have to speak to
him from a place of logic for him to
understand it he won't understand if I
talk to him entirely emotionally so if
you come to me as a man with a problem I
will say me and Nathaniel talk all the
time and I'll say I'll give him
practical advice because he's a man and
I speak his language he will give me a
more emotional advice because he
recognize that I'm a woman that's how we
have intelligent discipline I've been
giving you logical advice
yeah that seems quite that seems like
quite strong
yeah that's your experience like this
exactly but that's not a healthy
discourse you know I have this problem
and this isn't this isn't a you thing
it's just like a thing I hate it when
people come on and tell me how to talk
on my podcast it's like if you were so
good at it then you would do it and you
would make it bigger and so it's like
how are you gonna go to them and say oh
I know how to talk no no you don't know
how to talk it's just me yeah no I'm
talking about in this example for fresh
and fit yeah because I've been in this
situation I've been in this situation
where like a girl will say I don't like
the way you like they'll be like oh I
don't like the way she does this I don't
like this I don't like what like
whatever it is and I I my my first
thought is like how delusional are you
if you could do it better you would
because it's not about doing it better
it's about offering an alternative
perspective I don't care to do it better
than Marlon or no but but my point is my
point is they know what they're doing
having to listen to uh or read the book
of Seduction they talk a little bit
about this okay okay right where they
say
um let's say for instance
um my woman comes to me with a problem
yeah and I'm just going to give you a
logical solution because that's what
makes sense to me right when really it
doesn't land anything why don't you just
go why don't you quit your job then it's
making you unhappy it's like you want to
you want to vent you want me to show
some empathy that kind of vibe when
you're when a woman comes to a man with
the with the issue it's it's it's the
same it's the similar kind of thing
because she's expecting something from
him where it's like you know why are you
showing empathy why aren't you
understanding but he's just thinking I
see the logic in this it should be a
quick it can be it's like algebra we
want it simplified straight away and
it's like that's kind of the disconnect
so it's quite it's quite rare not rare
but it's it's nice we're obviously when
we have a conversation like you kind of
I understand how you would need it
um received and you understand how like
and that's how we communicate and that's
how we have this friendship for so long
and that's what I want to teach people
rather than women and this men are that
because you don't learn how to use those
skills to practically apply and create a
healthy relationship and if we have this
platform we should use the blessing of
it to improve lives rather than divide
people but they do improve lives that's
the thing like they they do all these
accounts people are now they do okay
they do okay okay Meg Tower is a whole
nother that's a whole nother group
fashion fit aren't mgtow they do they do
Improvement for men there's men that
have called in on their show and said
they that they they didn't commit they
didn't commit suicide so they are
helping Matt mgtow those are men that
were walking away until the laws change
and I understand that they want to walk
away from marriage and relationships
until the loss change I understand where
they're coming from I get that but it's
um not constructive to society if we
want to create homes and we want to
create two parent household me watching
a bunch of feminists or him watching a
bunch of red pills we are going to come
back with negativity towards each other
whereas if we take those platforms and
teach people how to communicate
effectively and create a home we are
doing more of a service to society could
I um I disagree with that
so I think that um anything that just
makes people chat and think is good and
it would automatically come to like a
good conclusion anyways I think that's
the shrooms
[Laughter]
I think your points are extremely valid
but I think part of the issue is that
we're told a lot especially as men to
change our word and change our dialect
change appealing to how women feel more
so than we are about how many times
I'm not talking about I'm talking about
um as opposed to saying like you've said
oh men approach things more logically so
it's more of a push towards understand
her first before understanding him which
doesn't give the unity that you're
afterwards like for example I have five
sisters I have a lot of sisters and my
mom has to explain to them that he I
don't process things like they process
things if they get emotional about
things next week they'll be fine the
week after they'll be up again and
they're like you're expecting him to
jump on with your emotions he doesn't
think that it doesn't work like this
he's not built like that and it's hard
for them to understand oh no sorry so
it's hard it's hard for them to
understand and wherever I've been told
to you know respect feelings and
understand they think differently as
well in the real in the world it's more
that side of it it's not like okay look
this guy's gonna think differently from
you it's just more accommodate to her
because she feels a certain way and
that's not what it was that's that's the
divide that right I had I had a
homemaker so we're opening um guys go
subscribe to what the wife School
Channel it should be in the description
um get us to 1000 Subs anyway Supply
we're doing a wife score and I and I'm
I'm I've been talking to different like
wives and homemakers that are going to
teach different like classes for it's
going to be fun and one of them
literally said she she teaches women
like [ __ ] your feelings it's not about
your like this is something she a
homemaker of 30 years teaches women [ __ ]
your feelings it does not matter how you
feel yeah and and so it's like when the
women say it it's okay but the men yeah
no I agree that you can't make uh
decisions on emotions but emotions can't
be entirely ignored because it's how
we're designed it's if I teach a man
[ __ ] a woman's feelings what kind of
father will he be
how will he raise a daughter I don't
know my dad that's kind of how he but
what kind of father you those guys are
in the comments saying [ __ ] feelings
[ __ ] women what kind of father are you
planning to become it's just it's not
even that it's more just like how happy
are you but that's the context of a
debate again that's in the context of it
if it leaves your mouth it's in your
soul contextual what if it leaves your
mouth it's in your soul like if I say
[ __ ] men men are trash even if it's in
the context of a debate it's in myself
no no but again like this is context
like he's saying [ __ ] your feet like
your feelings don't you can't your
feelings are not like what do they say
facts over feelings
so that's that's important that's all
right but do you did you see when they
there was a fight that broke up and a
guy and a girl they hit each other and
stuff I saw one clip of that yeah
there's a clip on fresh and fit and
there was a guest and a girl next to him
and they got into a physical fight the
guy started hitting the girl the girl
started hitting the guy I think they
both eat each other and yeah yeah that
does not feel me and then I only know it
because I watch Adam's sauce cast and he
who I love he um spoke about it he had
them on a set and he had one of the
girls that was in the set and she said
oh I just felt really unsafe in that
moment and Marlon was like [ __ ] your
feelings because she wasn't in any
danger what is it it's uh Myron Myron
okay [ __ ] his name
yeah you know I mean if you want to
communicate quicker and effectively it
was nice to just know the shortcut okay
cool she's not gonna take how I'll speak
to the guys about it she's gonna react
this way if I if I do it this way and
and obviously you know if if you're on
the alpha in a situation you can kind of
force your way force your way so like
you you can say [ __ ] your feelings and
maybe she'll just shop but are you
really resonating is she really
understanding or she's just shutting up
because she's like are you actually
creating a relationship in that moment
so I so when you said the thing about
you know their daughters that is the one
that is one of the things where I had to
really think all right I have to learn
how to communicate on that level because
I just think of my mom versus my dad
like my dad really
it's not about like
kind of does that with me I mean not in
like a rude way but like if I go to my
mom like I always say I go to my mom if
I wanted to cry about something if I go
to my dad I want a solution like I just
think men and women communicate in
different ways and we have as women no
business policing men and telling them
how to communicate why because if we did
it to you guys because but if somebody
said it to us it would be beneficial
again no no but they don't take it out
I still will probably want to give the
the solution right but if you understand
that what they need is the emotional
response you get your solution out of it
you can get you can do it in a way where
you still get the same Solutions I mean
I think it's about just the knowledge of
knowing that person is going to receive
it like this if you yeah but then that
depends on the level of their emotional
response which is why it ends up coming
to just [ __ ] feelings because you
have to take all of that out of it for
you to really understand what's going on
but [ __ ] your feelings won't make a
woman abide by you and sub-summit to you
when you say that of course not because
if you don't go crazy counterproductive
you just don't say [ __ ] feelings
you've got to do it in a different way
like hey oh listen take that emotion put
to the side pin that let's come back to
that Leo yeah I just like I just know
fans I just think you have no business
telling them how to run a podcast when
they're at a million Subs I just think I
would I would never go to an NBA coach
and like as someone who like I don't
know what you do with your platform I
don't know how big it is I know you
probably don't have a million Subs yeah
I don't because I don't know again again
again so so I just would never go to
someone and tell them how to do it when
I'm here I just think there's a level of
humility in that I know I know what you
I get what you mean but the point it
depends are you out for clout are you
out for to make a difference in people's
lives that's positive I don't care if I
have zero followers My mindset will
always be let's be balanced so that we
can create but why have a following at
all because it does help the people who
want to be helped and how do you reach
the most people through the internet
okay okay I'm saying like you could help
people in real life
like I just think it's disingenuous when
people say that because it's like then
go out then don't be on social media but
you help more people when you put your
uh positive advice on right and they've
helped more people the bigger they get
yeah well so it's like it's the same can
I stay away quickly yeah yeah
um you know what else I think is
misingenuous when people say um I'm
traditional in a sense you see that that
phrase right there I'm traditional in a
sense I feel like we may have a few
corporates over here do you guys ever
use this
do you see people use it like how do you
feel when you when you see people use
that kind of phrase because they'll be
like I'm traditional in the sense
because what it means yeah what it means
when someone says that is that um
I just have this thought about my
morality being like it's just you know
everyone knows morality is like always
evolving and it's situational and the
people that say that is just like oh but
my situation is like it's okay it's okay
you might you might are you traditional
in a sense no no it's true no I'm not a
traditional person
women say I already know when women say
I'm traditional in a sense it means I
want to be corded I want to know I want
to this is what they mean I want to be
courted like a traditional woman even
though I'm not one because I'm not a
virgin I'm not married before 25 I don't
have a cookbook oh but I cook one to two
times a week so yeah I'm traditional now
I'm like if you if I swear to God if you
had a conversation with the actual real
traditional women oh my God and I I I've
been talking to them for this wife's
school oh my God they run circles around
us they make all their meals from
scratch from scratch they've been
raising kids and in a kids like
situations where they're in charge of
children since they're like 16. they
even either babysitting this woman had
10 foster kids wow that's that's a real
traditional woman she's growing at her
garden in the backyard oh my God
fresh she's a virgin on her wedding day
I'm like I swear to God I'm so excited
to put everyone in the same room because
you don't even know how bad we are until
you see these women I'm like look it and
other do you meet many traditional men
um what do you mean I meet a lot of men
that
because we all meet men that want
traditional women but do we meet a lot
of traditions most men have Traditional
Values yeah yeah I know I'm sorry I had
to think about this yeah yeah what kind
of what what makes a traditional man I
think most men want to be protectors and
providers and most men are capable of
protecting the average woman yes so most
of the men traditionally would want a
woman that doesn't work and they pay
every Bill and she doesn't come on
social media and doesn't do all of that
is that traditional question oh actually
I have I have a second part to this so a
lot of women will say I can't be
traditional because he doesn't make
enough money I'm finding out now this is
wrong ladies this is wrong you're wrong
because you actually this girl raised 10
children on less than ten thousand
dollars a year it's because you want a
lifestyle you want a certain lifestyle
you can't afford you're trying to marry
the lifestyle instead of a family I'm
just I'm letting letting everyone know
letting everyone at the red pill
Community would they say that they're
traditional men or they're not and you
know what you know what I'll say as well
is um sometimes people will say they're
traditional men will say they're
traditional and they'll put off the
marriage thing because of the finances
but realistically if you if you if
you're Alpha and you just it's like cool
all our wedding yeah what we can afford
is this and this is what we're doing
because if we're getting mad we're
getting married it's not we don't have
you I know it's it's smart to have this
in place and and um like you want to you
want to move into the house straight
away afterwards but if you want to get
married you get married I think some
some women just get married for the
wedding anyway
I don't think that there's a such thing
as traditional men because I don't think
there's any definition of it I don't
think there's like any way you can sell
a man that they're traditional like with
a traditional woman you think oh yeah
like cook spread and all that [ __ ] and
does like version and stuff so what do
you think about traditional matters
exactly I can't think of anything have
you gone on dates before yeah have you
paid for your meal yeah no no okay
that traditional man wrong not not the
2020.
for the rest of your life to provide for
a woman no but it's one type of a card
at the end of the day
so press doesn't go behind baking the
cake and stuff I just feel like the
tradition based on the religion
an example of someone being a protector
if someone breaks into my house house in
the middle of night it's my job to go
out there and deal with the Intruder
it's not my wife's job that is someone
an example of being a projector
which doesn't involve anything to do
with money or anything else just pure
protection I'm willing to die to protect
my wife and my child and that's it
remember he said wife though not
girlfriend not something
because one would go to war to protect
women not their wife
but women no okay but regardless how
guys really well how most guys who I
speak to how they rate things are like
if you're my wife or you're my long-term
girlfriend you're all the benefits the
used to say this all the time yeah you
women want us to stand in front of
bullets for you and then you will be
rude to us you'll talk you'll talk about
us generically yeah the majority of you
will will say that you're settling for
this kind of guy you talk about guys
like this [ __ ] but you want them to do
all these things men talk about women
like this okay but you but you don't
expect it to go stand in front of a
bullet not for real so yeah
even even no no no no it's not extreme
because even being a single woman in all
of human history it's a privilege we've
never gotten to do it like being being
able to sit on this podcast as a single
woman that is a privilege because who
who do you go to I think back then it
would be a privilege now it's normal
because okay okay think about it who
runs and you you've you've never heard
this content before she's she's just um
she got recruited off the street too
which is okay it's okay but like think
about it like who runs the
infrastructure of society the power
lines
the the garbage collector like
everything that makes Society run and
society would fall apart without the
police officers the firefighters they
tend to be men if we go if [ __ ] goes
south and we go to war it tends to be
men so right now men protect us and
provide for us just by being a single
woman in society because a lot of those
Industries are 98 men yeah but so my
thing is so does that mean that's a
traditional man what like does that
equal equate to a traditional man I mean
I would say a man that's willing to
protect and provide for his woman is
traditional I think most men are willing
to do that the problem is women want a
lifestyle that a lot of men can't afford
but that's on the women because they
want a lifestyle outside of their what
they would pick they would pick a
lifestyle out over a family and I've
talked to girls about this where I'll be
like would you give up getting your
nails done for years no hair no makeup
no none no no new clothes nothing to in
in order to have a family like women
used to do that my grandma had 13 kids
yeah but I get this is so awesome off of
a fireman's salary yeah I get the
society thing that we need men for
certain roles but women dominate
education and education determines
doctors lawyers all the other structures
women also dominate child rearing and
with societies they're not just defined
by infrastructure it's defined by what
we the subcultures we create so yeah
like honestly the education system has
gone to [ __ ] since women took it over so
like there's actually negative course
like fun fact fun fact teachers have a
standard deviation lower IQ than the
rest of the population
I agree because I was a teacher for many
years and I know that most teachers are
they don't have to have high education
to be a teacher which is I don't know
it's not to say that women have no
values to say that women can live
without men or no sorry men can live
without women but women can't live
without men that's the point that's the
whole point but human that's this is not
no I think maybe
from a society evolutionary standpoint
I'm not talking about emotional I'm
saying you get rid of reproduction yeah
Society would go on and men would fill
those roles where women could not fill
the roles that men do we wouldn't we
wouldn't have night like the women
wouldn't be rushing to be plumbers we
wouldn't be able to figure out the
powers
but you know even with that you're
forgetting that for men they have really
low standards of living if they're not
motivated by women I think Chris Rock
made a joke is that men would [ __ ] in a
box if it wasn't for women you kind of
without the motivation of women men do
not strive it's part of their ego boost
so without that do you think a man's
gonna be risking it all to build a
really tall building for what if he's
got no woman to provide for I mean
we're not arguing that like women like
men don't want women and when they don't
help Society the point is that women
don't or men don't need women for
survival women need men for survival
that's the point and being able being a
single woman is a privilege and as a
thank you we [ __ ] on them that's the
whole point no I I just don't know if
you just want to disagree no I just
think that when we portray an idea that
one doesn't need the other we're
removing the need for codependency
we're talking about imaginary science
I think women in general just like to
feel more important than we are you know
that's like why we're told we're special
and queens ego boost men I'm gonna start
calling you Kumbaya bring everyone
so divisive I did one on gold diggers
and it was so devices and I got five
million views and when I do one about
how to solve relationship ratios and so
I'll get a thousand views so
unfortunately the people are hungry for
conflict and they're dying for it and
when we feed it to them that's what we
create in society
we all used to watch um
you got framed remember you sit there
and watch people like fall over and
laugh at them and stuff but we're
tapping into the wrong side of human
nature but listen it's just
entertainment not everyone wants
information
sorry I just think I would never go I
would I swear to God I would never go to
an NBA coach if I'm in the rec league
and tell them how to do it I just want
it I just want it but this is dialogue
you're inviting diet yeah but I'm saying
I'm just not performance is dialogue
dialogue is measured by alternative
perspectives okay I think he just liked
to argue I do I love this disease
but this is
[Music]
relationship
sorry you had something you wanted to
say go ahead I'll give you some like
time
it's a poor girl yeah no yeah honestly I
just feel so
like everything that's been said Has
Come From such a black and white
perspective so it's like even with the
cheating stuff it's like me personally
I'm polyamorous and I'm like
so
like I wouldn't wouldn't mind my partner
cheating because I wouldn't call it
cheating because I like open
relationships yeah
so it's like and then even the stuff
with the so
with men not needing women and women
needing men
I feel like we have different types of
women so many types of women that would
like to do the stuff that men do and
wouldn't mind do you know what I mean so
like you know more masculine women or
just even girly women that do stuff like
that so it's like it's just I feel like
everything's being said was such a like
so I I have a question for you just like
based on the last one why don't we do it
there's nothing stopping us so so there
are there are hard jobs that need to be
done to run Society so some that I can
think of are bricklaying
skyscraping or no yeah so I know the
exception right yeah but working at an
oil rig a lot of those industries that
that are hard jobs they're not always
the best like I mean they're usually
paid well but it's not like you're gonna
be get the status of a CEO or something
we we need those jobs and there's
nothing stopping women from doing them
but if you look at yeah if we look at
the numbers it's 98. if I'm doing them
just like
social normativity but do you think they
actually want to do it I actually ever
want to do that yeah
no but we do we do no we don't want to
do we have that bricklaying no we have
to exact things we have to do no but we
but we realize that there's stuff that
we have to do we do so if we didn't have
to do it they would so no exactly but
it's about you get that choice we the
thing is we there's certain things that
we don't
as a luxury for women for sure so I'll
give you another I'll give you another
example and you're you're new to that
like you've never you've probably never
heard of this stuff before so it's like
there there is um a TV show where they
put men and women on an island and they
had to figure out how to survive
the men within a day had like a
hierarchy of like everyone had different
tasks they were starting to build build
stuff they were getting the water clean
I don't remember exactly the women had
to be rescued within like two days
yeah that's a good point tribes women
would be able to survive in any climate
that's a good point
uh not not by and large not all all
societies that stood the test of time
were led by men
all all civilizations
that stood the test of time stood the
test of time had gender roles it wasn't
just by men
they had gender roles so men would [ __ ]
and women would gather that's how
survive they survived in neanderthals
where men would and women to split the
roles wouldn't survive so it wasn't okay
because safe men did go and hunt all day
who's looking after the kids their gene
pool would die so we need
balance in order but who needs who more
like let's just come on
women women need men more than they just
need women more just because for
survival of myself
purely on Survival men need women more
because I feel like men's hygiene
probably will fall apart a lot without
the women but it's actually totally
disease
exactly but that that's not relevant but
men have always what do you mean wasn't
it disgusting in the Middle Ages when
they were throwing [ __ ] out the windows
and stuff but I I they refer a shot of
the window alone
it was a male group
I've had some complaints from men on the
show that women in the west have an
issue with their pa
like Jay like we stay all right guys
come on the show and say they told a
girl to shower before you'd [ __ ] her
well yeah because people are gross
everywhere but
I'm just talking about like
okay have you ever been to like a house
where it's just guys in there and it
stinks it smells weird and then have you
ever been to a house where it's just
girls
and everything
okay okay
let's say the power lines all cut
tomorrow okay Purge
yeah so how how would you protect
yourself there's no guns here
so you're appropriately you live alone
what are you doing okay no no you got me
because my first thought was I would
like run to my brother
and my mother would save me so yeah I
don't know that's that's the only point
it's not it's not to say we don't like
women aren't important that's not the
point the point is like we need men to
survive and we act like we don't I feel
like okay fundamentally I feel like we
don't but just because we have kind of
been conditioned into allowing men to
take care of us so now like we've come
become complacent and stuff but I feel
like women do have the potential to take
care of themselves and take care of the
world wait okay okay so let's just go
back to the power grid example yeah
because how is that no no I'm just I'm
just just use a sample how how is this
conditioning so so the power line goes
out like now we're all on our own it's
conditioning because okay that's the
power line going out isn't commissioning
but if it went out like the way the
world is right now yeah just because of
the way the world has been and the way
women have been brought up and stuff
then we are conditioned to have to have
needed men okay but if we it was a
tabula Russell like everything reset
then obviously women will have the same
potential as men too no but the question
the question is a survival it survive So
my answer is that survival
like based on normal human stuff it's
equal but in this Society survival it
would we would need them okay let's go
back to before let's go back to before
this Society okay let's let's take away
all the buildings we're just on the
plane or whatever whatever the hell it
is and
someone comes to attack you what are you
doing
how how well no right but how you're
you're you said you're five nine five
eight okay how a man's attacking you
what are you gonna do
try my best to fight backwards okay okay
but you're probably saying it's gonna
work right right so it's not it's that
conditioning it's it's just that you
would die if you didn't get there
because I couldn't personally fight and
like in a way he attacks you yeah
I wouldn't by the way
I know it depends what you know what I'm
gonna say because I would know how to
like
knock someone out
I can take you [ __ ]
you know but this is the thing one one
one day there may be like a kind of
purge-ish situation right and I think
after that there'll be Vigilantes and
stuff like that that come to save the
day and they'll probably be men and then
I think these kind of Converse we
haven't had a world worn a little while
on it so everyone's getting excited and
talking out of us but when that kind of
stuff happens we will start to realize
um how things are sitting and and why we
need men and why we should value men
just yeah I'm not saying we shouldn't
just for the infrastructure that's been
put in all right gender levels is
actually necessary yeah because you know
men just like men men value the respect
I think men like play women place that
attention
and when value that that respect yeah
that's what I believe so you know I feel
like we get along a little bit better
you know if there's just a general
respectful for for men maybe because I'm
not around feminism like my culture and
stuff we're not feminists so I don't
understand why these conversations need
to be had but maybe if I've spoke to
more feminists I'd realize that they
hate men and they don't respect men so I
can understand why this is
yeah yeah because maybe when if you're
speaking to lots of women in the west
and I don't know that many and I don't
know many that like are feminists that I
don't really see the value in having
those kind of like of course men are
valuable I I understand it but maybe a
little bit is projecting though a lot I
don't feel like women really hate
schools but I think it's just women or
her and they're just projecting and
that's like they're just rejecting how
they feel how they project and how they
felt and it's just like you know
Miniatures this is where they just
they've just been hurt it's in the
language and there's little things that
you don't really understand like that
you don't really notice until it's
pointed out like phrases you ever hear
the phrase Knocked Up it puts the
responsibility on the man
but baby because he he knocked her up
well you meant to ask a woman her age
why a woman can easily ask you your
height and the man equally just takes
away the value from the woman what go
ahead when it puts the response beyond
the man it just takes the value away
from the woman at the same time
what do you mean I don't understand the
question so it's like calling a woman
Knocked Up it puts the puts the
responsibility on the man and then it
just sees the woman as like something
the man did right that's the point like
and no but that's that's the point yeah
is it is it's like you're putting when
you say he knocked her up but saying he
did it instead of like it takes two to
tango yeah and there's little phrases
like that you don't really notice that
are just in our language where it always
puts the responsibility on the man it's
like even with the the knife thing
people what did he what did he do to get
her mad instead of if a man was like
waving a knife at a woman like no one
would ask that question what did she do
yeah
um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats one
more time and then we're gonna do final
thoughts um so guys like the video also
subscribe to wife school I really want
to get to um a thousand subs and we're
really close to 700k
um let's see what we're at I'm gonna
look on my phone right now and refresh
it we're at 697 912 so
700k we started this show I believe it
was February 27th so it's actually mad
um that we were at like 20K when we
started now we're at 600 and wow
beautiful 97 000. so thank you all so
much
um okay so Ali M oh wait let me refresh
it just to make sure you have to refresh
the screen to make sure that nobody put
a super chat okay
um Ali M to all the men we love
appreciate and need you Edward um the
clip she's talking about on fresh and
fit the woman hit the guy in the face
when he was gonna swing back they
stopped him she started the issue Doug
MPA Kim Kumbaya just wants to argue
please stop hello wolf 343 we aren't
motivated by women we are motivated by
success beautiful and logical women are
part of success Ali m
are beautiful and loyal I read that
wrong ali um I'm begging you to mute
these people that don't listen and talk
over and kick people off who keep
repeating the exception and not the rule
it gets old Stephen I can't believe she
just said it's just a swipe of a card a
man has to build himself and then work
to put money into that card he just he
just uses to feed you Ted's fallback I'm
going to learn to be a good wife with
pearl I'm silly sausage putting your own
feelings at the for silly sausage
putting your own four feelings at the
Forefront of every situation and
conversation is selfish you are a
therapist how can you possibly not be
aware of that marriage causes divorce
men get post nut Clarity women get post
commitment Clarity ones that women once
a woman gets the ring house and semen
they change their mind and Chase divorce
and money silly thought oh my god post
commitment Clarity silly sausage it's
not F your feelings it's that we don't
live life constantly having to cater to
your emotions at any given moment 24 7
you are in control of your feelings I
agree with that I do think you're in
control of your feelings NSX correction
the girl ambushed the guy with a
microphone to scalp he slapped her the
woman on sauce cast didn't even watch
the whole thing and admitted it on sauce
cast women like you were dangerous 90
free-toe pie Miss K wants to be a mom to
the world that's women Jonathan Farley
who is the girl in the with the glasses
and why won't she marry me
what's your IG what's your IG Iman
underscore so spell it they're not gonna
know how to stop I Am A and E underscore
DT yeah they yeah in case you know I'm
just I I welcome marriage requests you
never know you never know
um Ted of Warnick F feelings is more
about the irrational feelings that are
used to justify canceling someone
because they said something that hurt
your feelings NSX EQ does not does not
equal more emotion EQ equals the ability
to recognize and control emotion
maintain um decorum and frame without
allowing your feelings to govern
government you men allow women to claim
high IQ so we don't have another
emotional argument Eddie women are as
loyal as their options if divorced it in
Grant free money they would stay stop
the cap therapist lady jomel Allen the
women hate Myron but says but says 90 of
what he says marriage causes divorce
high value men don't exist even guys
like Tom Brady Brad Pitt get thrown out
of the family home only money and semen
is high value not the man
MC heavy tit because sometimes these
names are weird MC heavy dance if the
woman
selected a man that leaves her before
the child is born that's her fault if
the woman leaves the man after he
marries her it's his fault she's better
partners and I'm just gonna say it Tom
Brady put the nail in the coffin not
even the goat can avoid female nature
don't even date them anymore guys you
see what they want smash cash and dash
dick Maxima she only watched the clip
section of fresh and fit not the actual
content there's a reason that Leonardo
DiCaprio dumps them after they turn 25
90 free till pie if step parents are
risky then why do y'all get mad when men
say they don't want single mothers scuba
mask tan mask is saying the the quiet
part allowed Doug MPA women think that
men have to take the higher ground we
don't have to do anything women make the
rules men are playing the game and now
Kim K is mad
um Ivonne I can't say your last name I'm
sorry it's long um the lady on the sofa
stop and listen to Pearl M.A thank you
for the Super Chat PJ Cornell marriage
only makes sense if you're talking to
the mother of your children if you're
taking the mother of your children out
of of the workforce to raise them and
care for your home zero Fallout 01
Society protects the lady so much you
can even write women without getting
censored that is that's why we have to
use words like X oh is that what XX
means I've seen that super episode okay
I've been reading super chats for a
while and they'll put XX and I'm like
what is XX but it's another way they put
woman okay oh Antonio
um Valdez thank you for the Super Chat
93 top High um
um you can step you can stay you can
post what you want but I don't have to
stay oh did I read that one already
um Spencer Caribbean yeah yeah okay okay
I'm done I'm gonna refresh this also I
don't know who the top Super chatter was
today but
um do you know who it was blessing
I don't know someone gets an autograph
marriage causes divorce um come on Pearl
slide me a wrench remind DM me remind me
I'll give you one
um Ali M to all the men we love and
appreciate you okay
um any final thoughts any social media
you guys want a plug you can do now you
can start and then go around in the
second row
um this was a very interesting
conversation I was on here when it was
all men it was a lot calmer but this was
a lot more
this is a emotional fluctuation yeah
yeah so but I've I speak to women every
day for like the whole of my life so
um so it was nice to have the girls on
and hear their views no matter how
conflicting they may be but um yeah it's
always a pleasure to come on here I'd
love to come on here again so if anyone
wants to follow me it's your host swab I
do interviews with UK artists mostly
um and Twitch streaming a whole bunch of
other stuff this uh your host swab or
one word on Instagram uh YouTube and
twitch as well nice yeah uh thanks for
having me on here
um Nathaniel also known as Natty ranks
um that's n-a-t-t-y-r-a-n-x
um it's a nice Vibe having I'm used to I
was in a podcast called the rap party
and we was just the guys so we just kind
of have like the male perspective and
sometimes we'd have uh female guests on
as well so now this has been interesting
especially for you as well I know you're
uh you've been hitting the shrimps but
but like it's just nice I know you're
kind of new to this atmosphere and stuff
like that so it's like nice to even just
hear
um how you've adapted to just train of
thoughts and stuff like that really cool
um I'm a personal trainer so if you do
need those meal plans or any gym advice
you know hit me up that's ranks regime
on Instagram as well
um yeah thank you yeah thank you to
power because I know we can have like
difference of opinions but it takes a
lot of work ethic and consistency to
build such a big platform and so to have
people on having their open feelings
it's still really refreshing and
impressive to do it so I know I I can go
on a bit but I'm really grateful for
this platform and for the people that
tune in
um my name is Sadia Sadia at Sadia
psychology s-a-d-i-a psychology on
Instagram and tick tock
lovely thank you so much for having me
again Pearl it's always lovely to be
here and it was such a fruitful
conversation I would say I always learn
when I come here so thank you for having
me yeah thanks for coming
um you want to go
um yeah thanks for having me yeah this
is really weird also I haven't been here
now I've just been microdising okay it's
not like I'm tripping
um yeah
um I'm a model someone booked me yeah uh
Aaliyah liked the singer on Tick Tock I
don't have Instagram
uh my name is Riz I'm Instagram's uh
d-o-n-r-i-z-l-a-o-f
um I'm just a standard person from the
from the roadside DACA cook like work in
different restaurants so y'all need food
stuff just hit me up on a grammar and
just laugh thanks for having me yeah
thanks for coming guys um this was a fun
panel today okay a couple announcements
before we end the show the first guys go
subscribe to wife school I really once
we get to a thousand subscribers we're
gonna post the video so make sure you go
subscribe um the link to that should be
in the chat and in the description also
sign up for our membership if you want
to be a part of the live chat set them
for the first year second tier you get
to be get to be a part of our Discord
and behind the scenes Vlogs third you
connect with me on social media and
fourth you get a one-on-one call with me
once a month guys subscribe to the
channel um we want to hit 700k I'm
hoping to hit it tomorrow that's that's
my goal but you know maybe Friday go
follow my Instagram just pearly things
one I want to get to 5K um they did yeah
they I was almost to 80 and then they
took it
yeah anyways
um also go follow my fourth no no they
took away my fourth my fifth and sixth
Tick Tock just pearly things dot five
and just pearly things six
um if you want to come on the show DM
the pregame show
um on Instagram so
um you just typed in the pregame show I
think the link to that might be in the
description I'll add it if it's not and
um I will
Kobe do you know the top Super chatter
was today
yeah I don't know okay well we'll we'll
post it we'll make an announcement who
the top Super chatter was anyways like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel and we'll talk to you next
time